this is Jocko podcast number 173 with
echo Charles and meet Jacque I'm willing
good evening echo good evening
sure analyzed the wound Wallen was
bleeding from his neck so he pulled out
gauze and started examining the wound to
assess the damage Wallens airway looked
fine
there was no vascular damage the medic
could tell that the wound wasn't
life-threatening but the blood was still
flowing you're gonna be okay he said
wrapping gauze on the wound
he began exerting pressure to stop the
bleeding are you sure Wallen asked yes
I'm sure
the fire was non-stop sure didn't think
it could get much worse until he heard a
frantic call from Walton on the radio
Bear Morales and CK had been hit and
they needed sure up there fast did you
hear that wall and asked yeah I heard it
sure sure said his bleeding was minimal
I'm good wall and said go get them
getting the waltons team though posed a
great risk a medic is taught not to put
himself in any unnecessary danger he has
to stay alive so other soldiers can live
but it had reached a point in the battle
where he had to go so sure grabbed his
bag and headed into the fire and that is
a passage from a book called no way out
a story of valor in the mountains of
Afghanistan by an author named Mitch
Weiss and it tells the story of the men
of Operational Detachment
alpha 3 3 3 6 it's a Special Forces Oda
team going after a high-value target in
the shocked Valley in Afghanistan but
when they got on the ground for this
mission they were in a bad tactical
position they were outnumbered they were
out
but they did have one thing that could
not be beaten and that was the will to
survive and the bonds of brotherhood
that could not be broken and on top of
those things there was incredible
courage on display from all the men of
the team above and beyond the call of
duty and one of those men the medic Ron
sure fought not only against the enemy
but fought to save the lives of his
teammates and it is an absolute honor to
have Ron here with us tonight to share
some of the lessons from that day in
Afghanistan and from the rest of the
things that he's been through and lived
through on his journey through life so
wrong thanks for coming on man
no thanks so much for having they have
you know honestly been a fan of the show
for a long time and you know and you
guys offered kind of weird to think
about coming on but it's definitely a
pleasure well man it's great to meet you
and you know we'll get to shock valley
but you know let's let's figure out a
little bit about who you were where you
came from how you grew up I know one
interesting fact to start this thing off
is that you were born on December 7th
Pearl Harbor Day
yes born December 7th the obviously a
few years later than 1941 but yeah I
grew up with that and for some reason my
parents always thought it was a good
idea to like get me news articles or
other reporting from Pearl Harbor and
sounds like a 6 or 7 year old ok read
this I think I don't know why but yeah
it always just you know was was
something that that we talked about as
as part of my my birthday and happy
birthday let me tell you about Pearl
Harbor side exactly yeah and in your
group where's your grandfather in your
grandfather's serve my grandfather did
serve he was in the Navy so he was in
the Pacific
four so here's he I'm trying to remember
he was on the smaller aircraft carriers
that they had around the Pacific so he's
on several of those aircraft mechanic
yeah and dodging kamikazes is for sure
another things I got a bunch of books on
in queue from World War two sailors in
World War two
it's those books are absolutely insane
what those guys lived through was
horrific
i I I look at that and maybe this is
just me I don't know how you feel if
given the option of being in an engine
room on a on a destroyer in World War
two hot sweating and by the way
kamikazes like you said or torpedoes are
gonna slam into you at any time and
there's nothing you can do about it
versus storming the beach I'll storm the
beach all day long like that's me I
don't know 100 percent I would rather
you know in you know land warfare combat
like if you're gonna shoot me I get a
chance to show them back and maybe this
will work out my way maybe it works out
your way but when you throw water in and
all those other other pressures like no
thanks I'll pass yeah I know I owe I owe
it to those sailors to cover some of
those books man those are those books
but you know with your with your
grandfather I mean just to live through
that I can't even imagine coming back
from that what your normal life is like
after you've lived through World War two
as a as a sailor in the Pacific Theater
oh man
crazy yeah my grandfather he he served
in the Pacific my great-grandfather was
in World War one shooting artillery
today at at the Germans so that family
history and and we have some family
history he goes back all the way to the
Civil War it gets a little you know no
more like cousin level and everyone her
hair but yeah they we've been wouldn't
fighting wars for this country for a
long time they've been both your parents
as well both my parents were in the Air
Force that's where they actually met was
in the Air Force and yeah we've just had
that family history or service that was
pretty normal and we and where were they
stationed would you spend most of your
childhood
I think like most military you know kids
I was born in Alaska but then moved to
Illinois don't really remember any of
either of those places first place I
remember is Mountain Home Idaho which is
just a tiny little place about an hour
south of Boise and then from there I
kind of called Washington State home
because I spent fourth grade on growing
up the washes okay so a big chunk of
time there yeah my my dad end up
retiring in 1991 from the Air Force and
then we just kind of stayed there
afterwards and then and you were the
only child
yeah so that one means those those
birthdays were especially heavy it's
like pure celery
I got four kids I know you got through
this I got four kids and you know you
can have a birthday and you don't even
I'm a my a bad parent I don't know
probably yeah probably yeah cuz it
birthday oh you know we do anything for
my birthday
I don't know when's your birthday today
oh okay anyways it's my wife blows it
out for our kids she's great at that
yeah I just kind of go along for the
ride yeah and my wife does a much better
job than I do as well
I'm the person that's looking at the
whole situation saying what is this
stuff hanging up for Oh what did I get
him yeah and then so going to school we
were you playing sports what were you
doing
what was your gig in in school I played
the usual sports growing up being a
soccer baseball what I really kind of
gravitate gravitated towards as I kept
growing up was your endurance sports so
I started my dad was doing triathlons so
I started doing that Oh your dad was
doing triathlon so yeah he did the
engine many trials he did the Canadian
Ironman a couple times and so I kind of
grew up watching that so I started with
triathlons in high school and then
pretty quickly switched over to just the
cycling Road road racing cycling and I
know I think I think those you know four
or five six hour days on a bike got me
ready for you
I mean on a bike right right I've never
raced a bike before but I know guys that
race bike and it's just pain it's just
how much pain can you take right
basically just you were long stretch of
road and you just keep on riding and and
apparently you've gotten some kind of
crash I know that I know that there's a
little disruption in your plans cuz you
get done with high school and you want
to join the Marine Corps or you get done
with college you want to join the Marine
Corps okay so yeah I went to Washington
State University was getting ready to
graduate in the spring of 2001 and so
started talking to a Marine Corps I mean
officer recruiter and went did that
process how's your mom and dad feel
about that they were let's face it Air
Force is one side of the spectrum Marine
Corps is on the other side at least at
least I was good I was talking about the
officer side on her when I later said
hey I'm joining the army enlisted then
they just they just lost then they're
like what are you doing you just but
yeah so I was getting ready to graduate
Washington State start talking to the
Marine Corps and went through the
process we they that was accepted
through the marine corps program to go
to OCS starting in October of 2001 it's
awesome but the Navy Medical Board had
seen what they thought was a flag on my
medical records from being hit by a car
in 1995 and sorry I never spent a day in
the hospital back then with pancreatitis
which usually would be considered
related to drug abuse alcoholism just
something serious or you have some
serious medical condition and so because
they told me no in August of 2001 that
now we're good we don't we don't need
anybody so yeah kind of
let's have to dry there and then so then
what was your plan from there I started
a graduate school and we're not original
degree I was Business Economics did you
date what you get in that degree but you
knew you wanted to go in the military I
mean you you or did you get done with
your degree and say oh no what I'm gonna
do now maybe I'm on the marine corps a
little bit of both so service was
definitely always a part of our family
life growing up and so it's definitely
in the back back of my mind I need to
give back do something for the country
never quite knew what and then yeah
trying to go to OCS just seemed like
something to do for a while and give
back and then when that didn't work out
I started graduate school to use that as
kind of a reset time I figure out okay
that's not working out now what can I do
and it was a few weeks into that that
9/11 happened and then we had to revisit
revisit the decisions again and so then
what did you do once what's September
11th happened so I wasn't graduate
school for for economics and I'm
spending it's been in that first year
continuing with education and just
watching watching it on TV and just
didn't feel right to just sit there and
watch it so try to figure out what what
made sense at that point to to do and
then for some reason enlisting in the
army sounded like a good idea so so that
summer of 2002 I went down an army
recruiter and of course at that time
there were like sure we'll take your
weekend we can scratch that we would get
what medical caduceus over here
now did you did you know you wanted to
try for SF at that point they they
talked to me about going in with SF
contract and it definitely sounded
interesting but a part of me just didn't
feel like like oh that I could be an SF
guy cuz I mean I grow up just like
everybody we're watching Rambo you're
watching other things like that's what a
green beret is like certainly don't
don't fit that mold but so they talk
about that but it's like well let me get
in let me get some experience in the
military and then we'll go from there so
I I signed up to be a medic who did
basic training creating the name right
now Fort Jackson mm-hmm South Carolina
and then mine off to Fort Sam Houston
and then went to Airborne School and
along that way I got I ended up getting
myself a Ranger contract - trying to go
to the Center for the Rangers so at some
point you you realize - alright I'm
gonna step up and try and go to a little
bit more special operation site
something got in your head at some point
yeah something got in my head and if I
remember correctly I think it was orders
to Korea that was my the first thing
that came through and like let me see
what else I could do so I I talked to
the recruiters got got the Ranger was a
contract that point but I got that set
up so it might be different out but
after after Airborne School you know any
infantry guys or ray or medics or
whoever's trying to go to to the Ranger
I mean you go out the Dex day wait on
the little lines out there at everyone's
school and they'd come by then look
through your paperwork pick you up and
take you take you over so they come out
they start flipping through everybody's
stuff
and they get to mine and they start
looking at my paperwork which is still
the same paperwork from trying to do the
Marine Corps post yes thing and so it's
of course a disaster it's you know not
physically qualified but then there's
like lines through that wavers and
arrows and just your nonsense but they
look at that and they're like well
you're not visibly qualified to be here
and so they just kind of drop my
paperwork took everybody else and left
me left me stand-in there
so now I had to revisit what to do again
so I ended up spending a few weeks
sitting there Airborne School just kind
of being you know a little assay you
know whatever they needed done that
sucked they'd make me do while I waited
on new orders to go somewhere yeah we
did I did that for a little while and it
finally got orders up to Fort Bragg to
go to the 44th Medical Command and so
well as you know packing up all my stuff
head up to Fort Bragg and fortunately my
medical records got lost along the way
did you say fortunately unfortunately
god I'm a specialist in the army you
know I don't want to lose stuff and show
up but it it got lost away so got
medical paperwork redone none of that
well none of those waivers or anything
call that situated reported to my unit
on I think it was a Thursday some
Thursday and in August have been 2003 at
that point that's because those those
are me the medic schools are a long time
basically so that at this point you've
been through boot camp army boot camp
and then you went to our to be a medic
how long is it training to be a like an
infantry medic the mid of course was
four months yeah okay so I yeah did
basic I did the
the medic school and then yet an
Airborne School and then that interim
time while they try and figure out
something to do with me and so I showed
up it's my my unit and after you in
process in August of 2003 you know that
first day we do pt then the first
sergeant calls me in like hey what do
you want to do with your your life plan
on putting in an SF packet try this try
something else again and and again the
thing that's draw what's driving you to
do that like did you see some SF guys
did you talk to some SF guys did you
watch Rambo again yeah what was the
persuading Factory I don't know I think
it was a mixture of a lot of different
emotions and I got I'd had nothing to
validate my feelings because I was just
some specialist in the army but I was
like I think I'm pretty good at this
stuff
so let me let me try and push myself a
little bit harder and try and find
something else to do so I I put in for
SF there's a guy named Travis Mills you
ever heard of Travis Mills he's an
awesome guy but he we he was on the
podcast and and he's a he's a quadruple
amputee amputee and he's like two got
the the damn spirit of a freaking like
the ultimate human being warrior but
anyways when he was grown up
he played varsity football and
basketball whenever he played every
sport he broke all these records he was
this big strapping guy taught like a
total stud just just a total stud and
you know I asked him I said well you
know how come you didn't try for Rangers
somebody said he's like hey or why don't
you try for Special Forces he's like I
didn't think I could make it and there's
like this thing where like for me I am
one-eighth of the athlete and the
physical specimen that Travis Mills is
but I was just Dumber which is dumb
enough and say oh I think I could make a
few this ready bring it on you know
he was too smart to say you know he's
too smart and he was too humble really
too humble because I had some level of
arrogance I mean I think there's a
difference between because that happens
on a fairly regular basis you know
special operations and special forces
has this kind of mythical build-up where
people start to think well I don't know
if I can actually make it through that
it's got to be so hard
whereas I'm always looking people like
oh you were a wrestler or oh you played
football varsity football in your high
school or you swam on the swim team or
whatever you'll be fine
like you can do it but people build it
up to that mythical level that you don't
think you can make it's all right the
reason I was asking that because it
sounds like you made a transition from I
don't know if I can do that and then
once you're there and you're looking
around you're going you know I think I
can actually do that you got
you either got dumber or you just got
more you know little and that's what I
think it is I think it is you know you
see you see yourself in comparison with
everyone else's there and you go okay
cool I'm hanging with these guys I can
probably make this happen so no that's
cool that's cool yeah and so you say now
we're talking that fall 2003 so
Afghanistan's role in Iraq is is going
at that time the the unit I was in the
was a medical support company they
weren't even supposed to deploy I think
the calendar had them going in like 2005
so I like girl you're like that's a
lifetime I way I came all the way here
do not go anywhere so so I put in for
selection we got we got got those
medical records are we done so I go so I
went in January of 2004 to selection and
now we can also talk about that more but
when I came back and then my unit is all
in desert camouflage uniforms and like
you guys you guys going somewhere and
they're like things changed in those
three weeks you were gone we're going in
like four weeks oh dang so so you went
to specialists so they send you do they
send you like ta D to special forces
selection is that what happens like
temporary
they don't transfer you there
permanently they just send you for a
correct for the for the three-week
selection process you just get temp
orders over
you do your thing if you get selected
then you wait for orders to go full-time
to the queue course and then that
initial selection is just like a beat
down yeah three weeks you know probably
different than most selections for
different soft units around the world
for a walk in the woods with heavy bags
get lost then we're gonna make you carry
heavy stuff and I remember logs a lot of
logs and he did care he'd apparently he
didn't belong over here they belonged
over there how'd you do in that did you
feel all right I mean honestly I didn't
know what I was getting myself into so I
passed I got selected but I didn't feel
like I was where I wanted to be for that
process it definitely beat me up more
than I thought it should and it it
helped reset me so I spent the next
couple months when I was getting ready
for those orders really resetting the
way I was training was getting getting
myself mentally prepared for it and so
once I got to the phase two of the
course I thought that was how are you
you were a little older because you did
college this was 2004 so I was at that
point 25 day was that older for maybe
20s that was going through not for
Special Forces
I was definitely one of the oldest guys
at basic training yeah when I was going
through but for for Special Forces it
tends to be those older guys who've been
in the the Army for a little while have
have seen stuff got some experience and
then you decided they wanted to explore
some different routes so you come back
from the initial selection course and
all your guys aren't desert gaming
they're good right so did they end up
the point quickly they deployed a couple
weeks later the deliver to Iraq or
Afghanistan they went to Iraq
did they do this did they run the cash
in Baghdad some of them were there East
doing I want to say they were doing
prisoner you know support there are some
of the prisons but luckily my company
commander pulled me in in their office
and basically said yeah you're on these
orders but if you wanna if you want to
go pursue something else I see some
value in that so if you want to go you
can go and sell your company commander
took care of you and said you can go to
the q course yeah that's awesome like
you know what's cool about that is that
guy just leaves a good impression on you
about the army you know what I mean I
always think that when I was a young
enlisted guy and somebody could either
you know maybe screw you over is a hard
term but you know some could either like
look out for you or just kind of let the
big green machine do its thing and when
someone actually looks out for you just
gives you such a much better
appreciation and in connection to you
know like I had guys that looked out for
me when I was a new guy
and I was that that just heightens your
commitment to the team you know that
there's people like that whereas the
people that try and you know you're just
gonna do this anyways needs of the Navy
that's what they say the in in the Navy
they say needs of the Navy yeah those
are the needs of the Navy so yeah well
and you're gonna get some and so after
my company deployed basically our our
battalion had four companies - deployed
- stayed behind so we kind of fell under
the two that had stayed behind and there
were some people over there who had that
attitude of you think you're better than
us like I don't I'm just trying
something different and so they made
life interesting for a little while but
we got through it
and and then so what did you train what
did you change differently about your
training when you learn from selection
like okay I need to work on humping a
rock more or whatever what was the what
were the big things that you learned you
need to do work on more weight and
moving faster I mean not to it's pretty
simple really look I'm not a big guy I'm
five six at the time I went to selection
I think I was about a hundred and
thirty-five pounds so you put on that
way and it's it's a lot so I I put on
some more weight I just got a little
more used to to move in with that and
because you got to carry doesn't matter
if you weigh 220 pounds or 120 pounds
you got to carry the same weight right
yeah the packing list is what it is the
minimum weight for the day is what it is
doesn't matter if you're 6 foot 3 or or
5 foot 6 you're just gonna go get
something
mm-hmm and then how was AQ course yours
and self I thought was a really really
good course I thought it I thought it
did a great job getting you ready for
you know things I had no experience in
so it's all it's all changed around a
little bit since then but so for me when
I showed up you go through a small unit
tactics portion basically learn how to
you know be an infantryman which from
from being a medic I mean I had the
basic training experience but I didn't
know anything really about that so he
spent about a month and a half she
learning how to move with with a small
unit you know just the basic military
drills break contact initiate ambushes
those things and then from there we
started the medical course which for SF
medics is a is a year basically just
learning every single thing they could
teach us in a year you know of course
trauma medicine was heavily enforced and
then you know just all the weird and
random diseases you might see around the
world and I actually met my future wife
during the medic course and so when I go
see her on the weekends
I'd pull out you know medical manuals
and be like alright start you know start
grilling me on these things and so she
pretend she had whatever random disease
you could get and they from around the
world it was it was pretty fun date
nights
I don't know why she and she put up with
it but she did so where were you when
you were where is that chunk of the
course take place is that's that's 18
Delta right yeah no of course
all ESF core the acute chorus was a
whole all based at Fort Bragg so I was
already at Fort Bragg so really I just
had to move across post when I started
and then are they when you're going
through 18 Delta are they still are you
still doing tactical physical evolutions
or is it like really starting to get
focused on classroom really focused on
the the the the medical aspect of stuff
there's a lot of classroom stuff because
they got a lot of yeah you got a lot of
teach you but they do they also do a
great job of pulling you out in the
woods and I can't remember all the
different segments of the course we have
a combat trauma lanes you have just so
many different portions where you get
used to you know treating people out in
out on the dirt and I remember sorry I
think I started that course in August
September of 2004 and so you know
rolling through the winter and I still
distinctly remember being out in the
woods in January when it's like 15
degrees and you're the patient and you
know like somebody there somebody's
working on you you know to their
practice you know like please do it
faster so I can I can get out of this
because you know you how do you treat a
patient who's wounded you have to expose
removers clothes so if you going through
stuff and they be like you know you know
do you feel this or do you feel that and
like the patients saying yes but no I
don't feel that cuz my feet are frozen
right now
but so it was a great course we did two
one-month blocks where you go out to
hospitals around the country and work in
the ER s or work with anywhere in the
hospital OB just different aspects go to
the local fire houses ride on the
ambulances get those experiences so yeah
the medical training that the and and
the seals used to go to 18 Delta are
sealed
corpsman used to go to 18 Delta they
don't anymore now they have a separate
course okay but the training that they
got and the training that the that
course provided is just awesome training
it's legendary
awesome training and who knows how many
lives have been saved because guys went
through that that block of training and
were just so good and at doing all this
stuff under a poncho at night stopping
bleeding working on you know healing
people with all kinds of you know in
inclement weather and the dirt like you
said all that stuff there's that the
training that they prepped our medical
guys for was phenomenal yeah I was super
impressed having been a medic before and
then kind of stepping it up a level like
that it was it was really really nice to
see where we're going to take a year
we're gonna really take our time teach
you everything you need to know from the
ground up
yeah and just continue to build those
basics you know from starting early on
with you know classes sticks and rags
like okay everything else is gonna be
great we're gonna teach you that stuff
but you know sometimes it's literally
just a stick in a rag you can stop a lot
of stuff you can save a lot of people as
long as you've had that experience and
then of course moving on later to
usually hemostatic agents you know to
like quick clot or something to really
stop but like okay this is easy now cuz
I had to stop it last week with
literally go find a stick and cut up
some clothes t-shirt now you're giving
me actual materials like okay I got this
going back to the Q course the initial
kickoff of the Q course was there
anything that you had major issues with
what do you mean like when you were
going through not selection but through
the Q course was there anything that you
liked I'm not gonna make it through this
I'm gonna fail this I'm not good enough
with this like for me I wasn't really
good at anything when I was like
everything that I did because basically
every week going through SEAL training
you get tested on you get a timed run
you get a time to swim you get a time to
obstacle course and then there's usually
some kind of a water evolution that
they're gonna test you on whether it's
underwater knot tying or life saving or
breath hold or whatever they've got
these evolutions for you and they're
stacked up and that's one of the biggest
pressures that that I felt going through
was if you for me like to pass a four
mile timed run which that when I went
through the the runs were not four miles
they were however long they happened to
be that day they might be 3.8 they might
be 4.6 no one knew soft sand high tide
and what I failed one run because I
decided I was gonna pace myself and that
was not smart and after that one run
that I failed I just had to go as hard
as I could for the whole time I'd said a
sprint as hard as I could and then I
passed and it was kind of the same thing
for everything like I just had to go
hard but you know I was worried that oh
I might fail another swim I might fail
was there anything where you were
thinking to yourself man if I don't if I
don't pay attention I might not make it
through this training I'll say any of
the any other time we're out and the was
doing infratry stuff because I just I
didn't have that experience I worked my
butt off trying to learn trying to pick
up follow the guys like okay that guy's
been a ranger school he's done this he's
done he started done to combat to point
me let me yeah let me hang out a little
closer to that guy and see see what he
does when we're setting up a patrol base
those kind of things
honestly I think like a lot of people I
have that two sides of the the corner of
me like I have that little bit of dumb
arrogance like I think I can do this but
then I also have that I don't belong
anywhere near these guys like these guys
are you know they've been there actually
done that I what have I done so I was
always trying to find that balance
internally of yeah I can do this or no I
can't I guess that's a big difference
between when you go through SEAL
training pretty much everyone's going
through training is not been there not
done anything before so even because you
might have been the regular Navy but
even most guys haven't even been the
regular Navy most guys are just caught
you go through boot camp you go through
prep course and you go show up a buds
and that's it that's that's what you do
so there's no you're not looking anyone
going on out of this guy this guy's done
stuff before or anything like that and
also you're not doing anything it in in
basic SEAL training you're just there's
no tactical there's just barely any
tactical knowledge being taught at all
it's like carry this boat on your head
for a long time and it's gonna hurt a
lot and then when it hurts a lot keep
going right in
I mean SF definitely has that aspect to
like you if we find the right people we
can train you at any point on what we
want you to do but we just got to make
sure you know you're not gonna you're
not gonna quit on us and I know I think
just along the way I was just I was too
stubborn to to quit definitely I
definitely wanted to all the time but
you know I was gonna give them the
satisfaction yeah and so so then you get
done with that you get done with Q
course you get done with 18 Delta and
then when do you get when do they give
you your Green Beret so for us I ended
up finishing the entire Q course in May
of 2006 so I done selection in January
of 2004 had a couple months break while
I waited on orders started the q course
proper in June of 2000
for and in May of 2006 when I graduated
dang that's a long pipeline isn't it
it's a long pipeline that's zero
recycles that's zero getting injured
that's just that's just what it is all
the other jobs are they teach you the
job at about three months whereas the
medic they teach it and twelve twelve
months so everybody else can be that
much shorter than than our pipeline but
so it was that May that's when I got the
Green Beret graduated the Thank You
course got my orders over to a third
group did you were you married did you
get married yet so I graduated the q
course in May of 2006 right yeah and so
I got that couple week break before
reporting to my unit mmm
my wife and I got engaged then so I
reported over to third group towards the
end of June 2006 and they say hey go
over to third Battalion they're gonna
get you slotted 3rd battalions like hey
go to Charlie Company and I show up to
Charlie Company 3:30 and there's there's
nobody there like like am I the first
guy here like what's going on and there
was one guy in there and he is like Oh
everybody's on block leave because we're
going in Afghanistan in a couple weeks
so I went home told Miranda the
situation and so we reading it a quickie
marriage but we didn't want to have to
try and plan while I was gone and then
there's also those aspects of you know
military doesn't give a damn about some
girlfriend or a fiance or anything okay
and so we you know we decided you know
she wants you know an actual wedding
ring an actual dress you know like you
know these few things can we get them
done we got it done
so we got married and then I you so you
didn't do a quick wedding but you got
married in two weeks it was like three
weeks
it was you know it wasn't like a elope
right away
because we'd been together a year and a
half at that point so yeah it wasn't
quick but it was it was pretty quick
it's awesome did your family uh how'd
you tell your family that next message
at that point it text really were that
because you had to type so many buttons
you know just a message so we ended up
bringing her parents my parents oh
that's awesome actually came down yeah
okay yeah we actually went where do you
do non quickie quick marriage Vegas so
we don't get met up there oh so so you
did a Vegas way and and we're still
going I mean what this summer we'll be
13 years all sober so yes we got married
did you request permission from your
sergeant to get married I did not I
guess he went on let you out of the
compound I just went on because nobody
was there so they just put me as soon as
I showed up I went right back on leave
kind of got married and it showed back
up did some training and then met a
bunch of guys for the first time and
deployed for seven months with him day
and and what was that first employment
like the first deployment was you
compare my second deployment it was it
was fairly tame that from fall 2006 into
2007 timeframe and Afghanistan we were
we were working with the Afghans you
know doing that setting partner with
them during then taking out on missions
I don't know which suite we just ended
up in Gardez Afghanistan and for some
reason was hard to find trouble then I
mean obviously things have been flow in
different areas and but just at that
time we really couldn't find too much
work so were you guys you guys were
training up these Afghan National Police
and to build relationships with them and
then you'd go out and do some kind of
missions with them but the AO that you
were in was relatively tame at the time
yeah so we work with the the Army and
the and the police just training them up
trying to get them ready to take over
their country that's the SF mission is
to train you up so you can do the job
and I I can go home you know obviously
all this half guys want to be a guy to
go in and you know blow up the doors go
in and clear it all yourselves but
that's that mission is to you know get
somebody else to go do it for themselves
yeah yeah that's it for those of you
that don't know that's that that is the
tenant of the bit that's the mission of
the of the Special Forces of the Green
Berets is to work with the whatever
nation you're in you build up their
forces you help them you train them
prepare them and and then you advise
them out on the battlefield and
hopefully with your goal of allowing
them to eventually not need your
advisement anymore that's what that's
what the primary mission of the Special
Forces is and well in the SEAL Teams we
end up doing that as well you know we I
don't know what trying to think of when
we actually started getting tasked with
that but you know we that's what we do
now - you know we probably we lean
towards you know direct action and
special reconnaissance that's kind of
where we learnt lean towards you guys
lean more towards you know training up
guerrilla forces but there's a lot of
crossover and and all of us do everyone
else's job to the best of our ability
but did you did you feel like the
deployment was like what was your
satisfaction level of that deployment I
I think most SF guys you've just gone
through alone trained up you've got all
this experience you're you're raring to
go and I pull em in I mean it was a good
trip but it was it was a little quieter
than I think most the team would have
liked you know if you're gonna be gone
and you're gonna miss your family for
seven months so would you guys say we
should take them out to hit targets and
there just would be you capture your bad
guy or yes or no but there they'd born
putting up
resistance yeah we did villages we'd go
we caught plenty of bad guys just they
had at that point I don't know I think
it was this kind of at a weird point in
the war where the bad guys really they
could quickly spot this is SF and they
didn't really want too much to do with
us so they just you know we'll pass
today we'll find we'll find another unit
to attack but yeah they just yeah we
caught we caught guys they just always
went pretty gate pretty quickly my week
we got in wait to get into a you know
couple I just a couple contact over
there but it was yeah overall it was
just brutal it kind of quiet area at
that was it wintertime so we showed up
there in August of 2006 and we stayed
till march of cute though I want to say
March of 2007 so yeah it was is that
winter when you're kind of have that
well anyways of the the winter time yeah
and like you said I mean things just go
up and down cycles go up and down people
the enemy gets agitated or they get beat
down and they take a tactical breath for
a few months or whatever and then you
come home from that deployment and your
so then what happens what's the life of
an SF guy when you come home from that
deployment you're gonna start a workup
to get ready to play again yeah we
already knew when we were going again
basically the at the time there was
three battalions aidar up standing up a
fourth Battalion in the groups so kind
of two battalions would be on the next
rotation one would be down and so it
just happened that my battalion had two
two back-to-back so to speak so we had
seven on and seven off and then seven on
again so we knew right away soon as we
got back when we're going and then you
try and cram in a quick work up into
that time period of course so you know
you got back so you got a first refit
get everything Reese
your way to make sure make sure you know
all the stuff he broke is fixed kind of
take a little bit of time just to
decompress and then start the train up
and you know we got got a few new guys
in on the team I've got a new team
sergeant we got got a new team leader a
couple other new guys and you know just
getting everybody ready getting on the
same page
honestly we the the team sergeant we got
Dennis got for it he was great coming
from he come from some training he come
from some some just different SF teams
that had been over to Iraq and
Afghanistan and had been there you know
early on in the war when it was it's a
lot so he he put us through a lot of
training got us got us much more
prepared than we were prepared for the
first read but we were even better for
the second one and yeah we'd finish up
that training do a little bit more how
the boys like that when you had the the
the new team sergeant coming in and he's
all fired up to push you guys hard and
trained he was any pushback from that
huh of course all of us are you know SF
guys and a little bit like you know even
though he's teams are he's been around
forever who's this new guy coming on the
team trying to tell us all what to do
right but you know didn't take very long
to see like okay he's got all this great
experience in and the training that he's
putting us through was was definitely
getting us hurt getting us ready and how
much how much support do you guys get
for training so do they sit do are you
going through organized training are you
guys running all the training yourselves
it's the company does coordinate some
stuff but most of its just had this heat
level so you know the team started it's
kind of the in coordination with the
team leader is kind of guiding the team
what where they wanted to be but then
you know as SF is broken down you have
your weapons sergeant suri
you know supposed to be your weapons
experts you have your engineers who you
know handle the demolitions and those
things your communications guys in your
medics and so depending on a day it
might be my data teach so I'm gonna get
two days this week to just put everybody
through mini medical course get them get
them ready just in case you know
something happens I can't get there or
something happens to me or something
like that
so everybody everybody is a subject
matter expert and just kind of tries to
try to lift that whole whole team up to
be the best they can be there's no
obviously each job is the best at their
job you want to know as much as you can
do about everything so that way
you know when things go wrong and at
that point it was kind of still
theoretical to me but yeah when things
went wrong okay I didn't handle this and
then you guys already knew when you were
going deployment and you did you know
where you were going on deployment as
well I don't remember when we found out
what our next mission was I can't
remember if it was early on or it was
late I think it was fairly early on in
our build-up that we knew we were gonna
be working this time with the Afghan
commandos which was a fairly new thing
at the time it was during that time that
the SF teams had just started Hecate
board and go through selection for the
Afghan army we're gonna get the best we
can we're gonna train them up more start
building these Afghan commando
battalions and they're gonna you know be
the SF of Afghanistan so I can't really
win but we knew we were gonna be
partnering with those guys to do a
little bit more of this traffic so you
so your expectation was that things are
gonna be a little bit hotter on the
second deployment correct did you
believe that as a as like one crews
wonder guy that don't done one
deployment are you like things are gonna
be hotter or were you just thinking hey
it's gonna be the same as last time
I think we all thought it was gonna be a
little bit more this trip just because
my first trip it was you kind of had a
little bit more of a region that your
team was so it just depends on what your
region is doing where is this commanders
gonna go anywhere the commandos they
were still fairly new so there wasn't
that many so over the course of the
second my second deployment and we spent
time in eastern Afghanistan we spent
time down in Kandahar we spent I'm just
going wherever they needed another
battalion because like I said there
wasn't very many they were training him
up but it takes a little while to get
get guys trained up mm-hmm so you go on
deployment you show up there and you
start working with commandos how was
your relationship with the commandos how
good were the commandos as you trained
him they were they were much better than
then you know an unselected force and I
think that's just you know as to be
expected you're still gonna have those
me know variances in your in your troops
yeah but don't leave felt more
comfortable so they were they were
fairly capable crew I they were better
understood and so you're out there
working with these guys on what type
what types of missions were you doing
just basically going after high-value
targets yeah yeah we would would get
intel on a high-value target we'd you
know trying to again going back to
trying to train them to do the job for
their country so we'd work with their
the team later for the team would start
working with the you know the command
level over there okay this is the
objective how how you how would you take
it and then they would kind of
coordinated yeah on a battle plan for me
you know I'd make sure their medics you
know we're training up getting getting
ready and then you know when it came
time for an actual mission
then each one of us would have a squad
or or maybe a few extra she's not big as
an Afghan commando squad they were
they're built around the same premise
says as a are an army you know light
infantry unit so you'd have you know
nine ten dudes just depending on what
kind of squad yeah you had with you on
any given day and so then you would be
running your squad of Afghan commandos
once you're out in the field you would
whatever that whatever just from it
you're no longer just the medic you're
now a little squad advisor for these
Afghan commandos yeah the medic piece is
always there yeah for for 18 Delta but
you know best medicine is superior
firepower so if we can if we can check
if we can go in we hit them overwhelming
force everybody's good we win talk about
how tough we are and then we go home and
so yeah the primary role is to you know
advise that squad leader on Mon how
things going and then you know we also
bring all the other assets that the US
military covers with all that you know
whether it's a helicopter coverage or
aircraft coverage so we can we're
getting those you know that that extra
Intel that we can then push to these
guys and be like hey this is going on
this is not going on let's fix this ya
know for me I think I just wanted to
kind of bring that out because it's it's
pretty cool when you think about it you
know you're you could be this young
soldier and you're out there and all of
a sudden you're working you're an
element leader you meet you go from just
being a medic or just being a demo guy
or just being a communicator all of a
sudden it's like hey you know what now
you're doing that thing but you're also
going to be advising which and
oftentimes means you're actually leading
this squad of commandos and you're
making sure that they're making the
right moves so that's a very cool aspect
of the job in my opinion you know yeah
it was when you could see them getting
better it was definitely a very
rewarding and as you see them start to
take more initiative
and start to you know be upfront with
you like okay that's that's cool to see
cuz I've been working with this guy for
a while and I remember one mission we
were doing downing in Kandahar they we
ended up getting Infeld and we start
looking at our RG RG the grid reverence
are they you know our little map to see
where we are and we're looking at it and
it's 1:00 a.m. 2:00 a.m. whatever it is
I'm like I have no idea where we are
we're not on this map so well we hear
some gunfire and like let's go that way
you know so so I have one of the
interpreters with with me when I'm blade
because they all want to mm-hmm knocking
about their real names in these
situations but you know later I'm like
blade hey let's get this let's get the
troops let's see her movement towards
gunfire and see what happens then we
start moving or doing our thing and at
one point I looked back and blades right
there on my shoulder he's doing his
thing like hey where is everybody
and they hunkered down kind of a couple
terrain features back like whoa we got
to go get him so but so you start there
and then you know over time that gap
shortens a little bit to you know
ideally where they're leading yeah what
was the op tempo like how often would
you guys go out and and hit targets it
would vary time time but with that that
training and advising piece we we
weren't going out like every night
because like we got to take these guys
from from ground up on mission planning
and everything so we're going out
several times a month to on bigger
missions and then other little things as
they came up and when you so it starts
off these guys are not wanting to get
anywhere they're not wanted to get a
shot at there if there's rounds fired
they're hiding a couple terrain features
away and
you're slowly progressing them building
a relationship with them getting to know
them to realize that they can actually
do better and that process is going on
and you arrived this was in 2007 you
guys had arrived in October in 2007 is
all right yeah okay
and then and then you're doing one two
three missions getting these guys trying
to push them each time to to do a little
bit more to take on a little bit more
responsibility and and this is just sort
of the way it is well and then what kind
of training are you doing on top of that
you're when you're back on base you're
running them through immediate action
drills you're teaching about a shoot
move and communicate that's basically
what's going on yeah
teaching those those basic you know
infantry skills take them out to the
range teach them how to clear buildings
teaching them you know just all the
things you need to continue reinforce
and then like I said once you've got a
mission like okay then we're gonna start
going through those those tape drills or
and build out a little village here as
best we can with our our budget which
was you know and start building that
stuff out so that way like okay we're
gonna bill here expect to walk this way
start you know go into those
choreographed rehearsals to get
everybody get everybody ready so now as
you guys got ready to go in the into the
shock valley what was did it seem like
just another mission did it seem like
all this one the seems like it's gonna
be a little bit heavier what was your
what was your assessment of it get ready
to do it
they were definitely a few red flags
that came with this mission but there's
red flags with with most missions like
they give us a gun and in training for a
reason like they don't ask you to go do
tickle fight with somebody else like we
you're always expecting something but
but you know it was just it was you know
we'd gone after high-value targets
before we had Intel he's over here we
had
until on what kind of what to expect so
you know was our the plan that we end up
going with nobody was super excited
about the idea of in filling at the
bottom of a mountain and then walk up
that does not sound fun yeah but it
comes to the point where you know like
hey this is the mission yeah alright
cool we're gonna do this mission the
best we can and we're gonna what what
happened what did you guys have to
insert at the bottom of that hill uh I
think the decision was made then you
know the Afghan commandos still being a
little bit knew like they knew how to
fast rope we done SF but how many people
do we want to risk injuring on that on
that and then just you know if there is
resistance
you know what's gonna what's gonna come
of that and and I mean I try to try not
to get too caught up in well maybe it
would've been better if we'd we didn't
filled in on top maybe we would have
caught on our PG a to the forty-seven
right away no no you can't play you
can't play that game I played that game
with myself and it's not a good game to
play now it doesn't mean that you don't
look at it you go oh yeah okay here's
what we saw this is why we made the
decision this is something that you my
brothers that are out there that could
be in the same situation were you gonna
make that decision consider how it
worked out for me right in and you know
this is well a couple a couple weeks ago
was eleven year from that battle but I
was actually talking to some SF guys not
too long ago and they're like we still
talk about that mission we still talk
about the the good which was the
teamwork the you know that everybody
coming together get this get this job
done as best we could and we talk about
the less ideal parts as well and and
make sure that we don't learn from
somebody else the mistakes don't don't
repeat those and I think that's a great
part about SF is you have that
humbleness like hey we did not do this
right you know please learn we did this
right please learn
and and yeah and and again the other
side of that is like you could look at
this thing all day and say well you
should have gone and fast-roping on and
like you said you take an RPG and the
one of those helicopters and there's
nine dead guys or whatever and you go
okay well I guess that wasn't a good
plan right so you can make the best you
can make a horrible decision and it can
work out well you can make the best
decision it can work out horribly so
whether that that's like a that's the
way it is so what you do is try and
learn from it and look at what you did
and say okay well what could we have
done better could you tell from the the
imagery and or the maps of the area what
that terrain feature was like cuz I'll
tell you what I wish you know I was in
getting ready for this podcast I read a
bunch about the operation and I kept
reading steep terrain and you know this
that the other thing and then and I kind
of calculated in my mind you know what
that looked like in my mind and in my
mind it was it was pretty bad it was
like okay must've been pretty
challenging then I went looked at actual
footage cuz there's a bunch of actual
footage because you guys had a combat
photographer and you had a bunch of
overhead cover I saw that terrain
brother I could not believe it I was I
was I was saying oh Mike like as bad as
everything sounded it was ten times
worse when I saw that terrain
I was like I can't believe that this
that these guys did this I agree yeah
yeah and I don't just mean that for Mike
he inserted there I was saying were the
fact that you guys went up there that
everything that you had to do on that
operation because the terrain was so
steep I couldn't believe that you guys
got out of there I mean it was just
crazy like you know I mean you get used
to you see the predator imagery
beforehand to kind of get a feel you've
seen satellite imagery get used to
saying that stuff and you kind of you
learn to build in that variance of this
is what it looks like there but I know
it's not gonna be like that and so you
kind of you're building your right and
your left limits like this is a part of
what I think I'm gonna see yeah and it
was still a little bit more than and at
least for me of what I was expecting
yeah it was no joke it's it's a
borderline
cliff I mean it is steep and anyone
that's listening to this you can go on
YouTube and you can google battle of
Jacques Valley and you'll you'll start
seeing what I'm talking about it's it's
it's some heavy steep terrain with a
damn fortress on the top of it I
couldn't believe that either I was like
all that that is a fortress
how many Afghan commandos did you have
with you we inserted was right around
100 okay of them and then some my team
you know so I go through it in my head
about 12 dudes it when you when you add
it all up we had about a hundred
commandos and then we we had a another
SF team that was kind of further down in
the valley trying to act as a blocking
position down there and so but our main
assault force I mean it was about 12
dudes that kind of where that main
assault yeah on it so so you guys you
you look at the plan everyone's kind of
like hey it's gonna be steep it's gonna
be tough this is what we do let's go get
some yeah we made we made some like
accommodations for that like given what
we're doing today obviously you you
always want your secondary but you know
if if that beretta doesn't walk up the
hill with you today like we understand
we got it we got to cut some ways you
just heard yourselves down a little bit
a little bit later we did pare down what
body armor oh we still went with with
the plates that was still with the
helmets and when you're doing those pre
combat checks with your your your Afghan
commandos that was always the fun part
is they super motivated to be there and
I remember one time we're going with
their pre combat checks with a 240
gunner so we got a belt-fed machine gun
you you carry this this is your job I
start going through and I find you know
the first m4 mag on I'm like all right I
mean you don't carry and I'm for but I
get it and we ended up finding eight or
nine m4 mags on this dude like
Karim Karim or 762 for the belt-fed like
I appreciate though you know you want to
want to be ready but focus focus in
where I need you honey that's kind of
crazy so so you guys so how many how
many helicopters was it that was
bringing you all in there must have been
a big package and did you go in all at
once
like one giant lift it was yeah one lift
like day it was a couple a couple
Chinooks couple Blackhawks everybody
going in and then like I said there was
another team that kind of Infeld down
there with a smaller commando package
and we had you know some medical QRF and
stuff up in the air a few other things
you know so we definitely had what
seemed like enough a good orange so you
land in there and how long does it take
before you realize like well okay this
is this is we took a big bite well oh oh
right so I was the first guy get on the
Chinook saw that were my last guy to get
off you know you know and just having
that responsibility to make sure
everybody gets off gets up safely and so
we hit the zone we hear the go and
everybody's getting off helicopter so
incredibly slowly and you know I mean at
the front so I'm in the back of the line
I don't know what's going on I'm just
yelling at commandos like get off of
this helicopter now like the more time
we're sitting here the more if if there
is a bad guy watching us we're just
giving him more time to watch us so it's
just taking forever and I finally get to
the back of the Chinook and I look out
and I'm like oh we're like 15 feet off
the ground
the the valley that we're in is just so
rocky and so such horrible terrain even
they're like they didn't land like oh
okay this is why it's taking so long so
like everybody else in front of me I
very carefully you know
down try and shimmy off the backs I'm
not breaking a leg before I even start
off to a good start
yeah it's very strong so so we we get
off the the Chinooks fly away and then
you just kind of get that that cold
quiet of an Afghan valley you know
there's that little bit of ice in the
water there you know it's just you don't
want to use the cliche like it's too
quiet but but but yeah we just gotta get
out there how far did you have to patrol
up the valley before you were you know
perpendicular to the target building or
the target Castle because that's what it
looks like it I mean it you know in
hindsight and you know you're seeing up
there like I mean they had fixed
fighting positions ready to go or sure
they were it looked like a castle they
were they were set I would guess 400
meters somewhere and we got basically we
Infeld just basically trying to use
angles just to make sure like we're not
that far away so if we have some element
of surprise we don't waste it all but
not so close that you know we're already
in it before we get off so yeah it
wasn't that far so you weren't on the
ground very long before you started to
you start you took fire from these guys
from the castle yeah I couldn't tell you
how long before the castle started
shooting at us I could have been 5 10 15
minutes I don't think it was that long
so I was in the trailing element
basically because I was the only u.s.
medic on the grounds there I had my
Afghan commando medics but I was the
only only a team medic there are you
know SF you were supposed to have two of
this job to have that job to the next
unfortunately the the
their medic on the team had been hurt on
a previous mission and then while he was
recovering from that he was in a vehicle
rollover which didn't help so he got
pulled out so yeah
I'll still do it so yeah just 10-15
minutes maybe at most we start walking
walking up there you can see the the the
lead assault force starting to work
their way up and yeah everywhere it's
super steep on both your left and right
as you're as you're kind of looking at
it and they find one little area where
you have those kind of terrorists like
farm terraces kind of working up and
that's where they do figure it out okay
what we're gonna work our way up there
and so you can see them starting to make
progress up the up the mountain and then
I distinctly remember I saw one dude
just in blue you know blue Afghan garb
sprint across the top of the hill with a
with a rifle and I don't I mean I don't
think he's the dude who started shooting
at us but I saw that and then within a
few seconds mm-hmm everything just kind
of opened up on us and got the day
started yeah I one of my little sayings
is always take the high ground or I'll
take you and this was just a situation
where you guys dude you guys and you do
not have the high ground at all you guys
are literally in a valley how long was
it before you took your first wounded
I was pretty quick Oh so we start taking
the the fire I my first job is is to my
squad I think commando squad so I start
getting them situated there's not much
cover in there it's just smaller rocks
bigger rocks but with that elevation and
at various points I mean both sides were
kind of shooting at us so I start
getting them situated and then very
quickly I heard the first call for medic
one of the Afghan commandos had been
shot luckily it was a fairly minor wound
so I ran over to him started treating
him and while I was working on him just
assessing the situation that's when I
remember watching many RPGs coming down
but one RPG in particular come down hit
right in front of our lines that that
guys were starting to form down in the
in the in the valley and then I hear the
calls for Ron coming down and so I know
right away like Brian Wallen had just
been hurt like I just know that right
away because before every mission
Brian would come take his squad of the
day and stand in front of me and and
hold them and be like this is wrong
something happens to me find wrong and
you get the next one this is wrong
something happens fine wrong good
insurance policy and so they you know
when they're not calling for medic
they're just calling for Ron like okay I
know he squad that is so so yeah kind of
did that quick math like okay this guy
he's fine he's he's really not gonna
live or die based on anything I do suck
it up grab he had a saw like grab your
saw start shooting back good luck and
ran over towards we're head that that
next call and like you'd read earlier I
find Ryan bleeding pretty pretty
profusely from neck and of course now
you had a neck injury and you got to go
through those quick calculations like
normally how do you stop bleeding lots
of pressure like well
I can't choke him to death no turning
it's gonna work out here so yeah just
that kind of started the my day of
improvising like try to figure out how
to get pressure and I don't even
remember exactly what I did or just
wrapped it over the neck yeah you just
cut cut shrapnel I had several shrapnel
wounds and in there but you know you're
just doing those quick quick assessments
okay there's no bubbling which means
bright and hid airway you know it's it's
bleeding a lot but not bleeding that
fast that I think it caught a carotid or
something like that so it's a pretty
lucky neck wound yeah if you have to
catch some shrapnel to the neck he did
it pretty well so yeah why as I was
working on him everybody's trying to
just figure out what's what's going on
the mindset that we're still assaulting
this thing oh yeah Dane now wait we
didn't just trumped me in in mental
attitude because I would have been oh we
just got launched by the way used that
you said we get launched many RPGs
when I get launched many RPGs at me from
an elevated position on assaulted that
target we're going somewhere else and I
got a wounded guy got two wounded people
yeah we're not we're not going any
further up this hill we're shooting RPGs
back at and we had I uh I legitimately
could not tell you our Afghan commandos
real name but he just he knew his name
was Joe Pesci that's that's what we
called him he looked like Joe Pesci he
was he was our Afghan commando RPG guy
and so he was kind of like looking at
all of us and look at the mountain and
pointing up there and pointing it as RPG
and Mike hell yeah dude don't jump
you'll get from Joe make it happen and
say yeah let's see some Goodfellas right
here yeah so Joe Pesci started shooting
back so we you know start getting given
back as good as they were but so yeah
all that's kinda starting to go on you
know worried when Ryan trying to figure
out what am i you come back and get my
squad what what needs to happen
and that's one here on the radio the
call from from up on the mountain that
multiple guys were now now wounded I'm
pretty sure the the call was that you
know the three guys at Point or wounded
so yeah basically told Ryan you're good
have a nice day and grab my stuff just
started working towards the mountain our
team Lee team sergeant Scott Ford and
one of the the weapons guys Matt
Williams they started organizing a
response for us to get up there and
start flexing a little more muscle up on
the hill so there they were going to see
not my focus is hey I need to go so you
know hit the mountains start working
stuck my way way up the same terrorists
features that I talked about before and
you know it is climbing hand over you
know hand over hand you're literally
climbing get up to the next Terrace
figure out how much are we being shot
out right now where is it coming from
where's the next place I can go up and
just start working our way up as we went
up you know the the other support
element kind of got got with me and we
also started taking that terrain
together took took a while to get there
I don't I don't know they they put out
their estimates with I don't know how
long it took me to get there got up to
the the little outcropping that had
become you know where that were the
where the command element was what it
was and sort of processing the situation
that we had where as I right as I'm
looking at it I can see one of our
interpreters CK he appears to be gay
two of the two of the team guys were
down with the
different wounds and so I started trying
to go through the fastest you know
triage that I can to figure out what I
need to do and and I mean honestly even
at this point where I don't think the
calls made quite yet that we're done for
the day but it was gonna be it was gonna
be called very soon yeah after that so
yeah trying to remember the full
sequence and it was a busy day so I
think I started working on Dylan first
just cuz he looked the worst off he had
a gunshot wound to his right arm and
another one to his hip pelvis area his
his arm unnai Chokin him now cuz he's
he's fine and it's okay to joke about
getting shot after the fact but you know
joke with him a you know that one ball
that hit his arm it was it was just a
lucky bullet for him but it went through
his his for speaking words it's tough
sometimes his uh his rifle strapped it
went okay sling it went through his
sling cut it cut that then went through
his arm and then he chose to keep his
pistol on that day but at the time we
were still kind of running a pistol on
the front of your body armor and so it
had actually lodged in between his plate
and is his pistol I hit the inside of
his his pistol that just slightly
different angles on that bullet and yeah
yeah so his arm wound was basically just
a very minor blade didn't worry too much
about that but it didn't take me long to
figure out his his his other one was
gonna go to me literally a pain in the
ass for him all day
figured Italy for me but it was you know
you could just see the way it's bleeding
and it's just you know those very small
wounds entry so I made the made the I
would say dumb comb for just a few
moments I don't even know how long it
was I didn't want to roll him any more
than I had to to to see what was going
on so I for a little bit took my helmet
off set it to the side so I could just
roll him just see the downside wound how
bad was it
it didn't end up being that bad so gonna
roll him back over and hopefully I put
my helmet on right away or thinks maybe
somebody yelled at me but so just
started working on trying to figure out
how to get pressure on there you'd
mentioned we had the comic cameraman out
there with us by that point his camera
had already been shot so he he just
became an extra an extra set of hands
for me to to help so okay let me go
triage the rest of these guys are quick
just hold pressure here for me I'll be
back in a second and you know I say I'll
be back the area we're working in was
not that bag use maybe 20 meters across
and it's just that that slight slope you
get on a hillside before it falls off
the cliff so to speak and everybody's
just hanging on that tiny little bit of
a slope trying to not fall off and not
get Josh and the guys had been shot
where they on that slope and I got shot
oh they pushing up a little bit will you
will you somewhat safe in that shot
where you're in that spot were you
somewhat protector was guys still get I
guess they weren't you still guys were
gonna shop no guys were still still
getting shot
so we're basically you're just trying to
use that tiny bit of an angle to
minimize how much you can be shot at
there
there was no place where you were safe
on there at all if you kind of picture
like from from from that little
outcropping where we were if you're
looking at the main village it was
almost like like a hockey stick kind of
in front of you is the way the mountain
kind of wrapped around so yeah that long
wall kind of on what I'm considering my
left but then it's still wrapped around
so the whole village if you got a little
bit of cover from this side you're
exposed to the others yeah the other
side still had you and then there were
some people on the other side of the the
valley who were shooting this too but it
was much it was insignificant compared
to other problems we had was your
mindset at this point totally focused on
just getting to get working on the guys
did you go into that mode like oh okay
but this is what I got to do or was any
part of you going this is not good did
any was it any party that was saying
hold on a second look at what's
happening situationally we're surrounded
they have the end the enemy has the
upper ground I got wound 300 guys what
calls being made well what was what was
like your tactical assessment of what
was happening or were you just
straight-up working on guys trying to
save their lives from my perspective it
was straight-up working on guys at that
point the trying to get my commandos and
you know leading them anywhere that was
over for me
I would I would find them hours and
hours later and they were like they were
still down in the valley just hanging
out trying to use a little bit of cover
and they all kind of saw me and they're
like we thought you were dead oh while
ago thank you welcome back Thanks so I
said we were working on closing those
gaps with them but come here sometimes
they're advanced all broke but so yeah I
was mostly focused on just trying to
treat these guys
and you know hits you need to convey
information to the team leader and you
need to tell the guy you're yeah you're
your fine buddy you don't don't worry
about that so at one point you know I'm
telling done you're good dude we walk
this off and then kind of looking over
the team leader man like no seriously he
needs to go back right now he needed to
go a while ago but now we'll be fine too
so and I didn't really think about his
perspective on it but you know later
he's like yeah I was hearing at all -
like sorry about that that's that's a
rough way to hear things so so you had
three guys wounded in that position as
well so there was the the three kind of
an it the two Americans initially credit
critical and the one again and ie
so I started working on Dylan went over
to Louise saw what what what had
happened him Luis Morales and he had
been shot through the thigh and through
the ankle both on the right side and
luckily it didn't hit any of the major
vessels but it like for this his thigh
it it just ripped it in half like you
could look all the way through his thigh
look like you cut up and a fish and you
were gutting it and so while he wasn't
he didn't hit a major artery it's just
so much tissue damage that this could
still form compartment syndrome could
still kill him many different ways so I
start working you know assess him and
you know just doing those first sweeps
like I'm not trying to do anything
definitive yet it's just like let me
figure out what all is going on and then
I'll come back through so after seeing
Lois I still felt like I owed CK an
actual check this was the interpreter
the interpreter he was he was dead but I
still owed him like unless unless I know
what killed him maybe he's still alive
so I went up
to check on him he'd been shot just
behind the left ear and yeah it was it
was in unsurvivable wound yeah so I
checked on checked on him and then you
know we just unfortunately with his
little cover as we had for anything like
he couldn't take up space where we had
cover so we we just kind of had him off
to the side a little bit but exposed to
the elements because you know
unfortunately in the living guys didn't
have enough space so after checking on
him I kind of go back through and
obviously this entire time we're still
getting shot I still feel those bolts
gone by I could still feel the the dirt
kicking up you know there's just
everything's so tight in there in so
little space like I'm trying to kneel
over these guys to do the best I can for
them and and as things are just falling
on us trying to cover them as things you
know I'm just rocks are coming down
explosion they're happening just running
now yeah at some point they start
calling in for fire is that is that
happening yet the coastal fire came in
they started pretty quickly um Zach
Raynor was our Air Force combat
controller that day he got the Air Force
cross very deservedly so I mean you know
all of us are alive because of all the
stuff that he called in day yeah
he's dropping bombs Danger Close drop in
two thousand pounder I mean he's
dropping the stuff and again you know
why I'm talking about this as if I know
what it looks like because I saw you can
watch these videos and you can see the
bombs hitting and massive hitting that
castle and massive bombs hit in that
castle and even even the bombs that hit
that castle a day they do damage but
that castle was massive and raizy you
know we ended up through the course of
the day one at one of our Afghans
broke his leg the wood framing on a
building they got blown up broke his leg
so we got to deal with that you're
getting just all the other wounds that
are coming with those because this
because massive debris is coming down on
you guys from those danger-close hits
bomb drops and like debris is coming
down on you guys because you guys are
below it down a cliff right at at one
point I don't remember exactly where in
the sequence of events basically I could
say we kind of had that wall on our left
that went straight up and there was
there was a building there and they were
getting in that and starting to shoot
down at us and so that had to go away so
Zach ended up calling in a strike hit
that and I don't go hunting too much for
footage online but I don't have seen it
through the military side you can you
can actually hear the pilot come on the
radio after he drops that one he's like
I do not feel good about that one yep
that's how Danger Close it was a so
Danger Close that the pilot comes on the
radio afterwards and says he goes that
was real close I don't feel good about
that one meaning you could hear the the
sickness and his voice thinking how you
know did we just kill our own eyes you
just killed everyone and of course for
us you know we're covered and we're
getting covered in debris we're getting
just rained on stuff but we're like
thanks it's totally insane so at what
point did you guys decide okay we got to
get out of here or were you still think
that people just get this assault up
Dale at that point we were pretty much
pretty much done at that point
so scout for the team sergeant he comes
in like I said he he was you know right
there with us moving up the hill
bringing on those those extra guys and
he started I'm working I'm trying to
keep these guys alive and he starts
working that let's get them out of here
peace so our lead element it actually
made the edge of the village
like I think they got into at least one
building so they're certain oh we got
that foothold like we were we made it
guys we won but so he makes that call
okay we gotta we gotta pull those guys
back yeah to start getting which is
actually incredible to even have gotten
to that and and to be honest with you if
things now that I'm you know I'm talking
about how much I would have just you
know bailed out of there once you get a
foothold in that situation now it's you
know it's gonna be CQC us-against-them
like you you actually have a pretty good
chance you know will you've got 100
commandos or we get them up that hill
you get a foothold in that building it's
like okay
or in that in that castle we can start
taking it out so that's that's
impressive man props to you guys for
sure
yeah the unfortunately as bad as it's
started for quite a while through the
day it actually kept getting worse like
it never stopped I think we started to
get some lulls after we'd done so many
airstrikes but so the the side of the
mountain that I went up a little bit
later in the day like he was just
no-man's land
you didn't go over there if he wanted to
not be dead so the logistics of trying
to get an actual fighting force up even
though we had a foothold you know it
just became an untenable position so you
know I'm working on these guys I'm I'm
trying to get some kind of hemorrhage
control bleeding control on on Dillon
you know with Lois I didn't quick-quick
treatments on him got his bandaged up as
well as I could so that way you know
just well that trauma he didn't end up
you know still still dying on me on the
mountain just from from some something I
started working on Dillon and I said it
based on what he was describing to me
like I didn't see the point of like you
know in the meta quest they teach you
like oh you can you know press on a
pelvis down and then you squeeze it and
that's how you'll see if it's broken or
not like I didn't see the point in doing
that to him just where the wound was
like something in theirs broke
he's not gonna benefit from me jumping
up and down just on it to find your
pelvis is broke sorry about that
so but he was also describing like oh my
foot doesn't feel like it's straight
like nothing feels like it's lining up
right no it wasn't because the find out
later the you know the bullet had gone
through his femoral head so I shattered
that I did a bunch of damage to the
pelvis itself so I'm just seeing this
I'm looking at what like what I can
physically see Emily I don't think it
hit an artery but if it hit the pelvis
and it's been awhile since I was a medic
but you know I remember having those
those numbers in my head like okay a
pelvic fracture he's gonna cause this
much bleeding and a femoral fractures
gonna cause this much bleeding and
trying to process those things like okay
he's not he's not bleeding out but he's
still gonna bleed out yeah on me so it
was so high up you couldn't put a
tourniquet on it couldn't really do
anything so I just came up with idea
that I had SELEX hemostatic agent it was
designed to stop bleeding
I had a powder of that so what I did is
I just kind of started pouring that on
the wound and I'm taking my fingers and
shoving it into the moon because the
wound was so small the entry wounds are
not big so just start shoving that in
there trying to get as much in as I
could just repeating that process over
and over until I felt like I had enough
just it was just scientific just just
kind of gut call shoving fingers in your
buddy
be like hopefully those will help then
wrap them up as well as I could and so
while I'm doing this that's when the the
lead element started to get back towards
us and they were gonna help us start to
get these guys out of there and within
moments maintenance whatever it was of
them getting getting there that's when
we took our next American casualty John
welding had been hit mother right right
Lee just below the need basically just
and potato just like right away it was
hanging on by a little bit but it it
just amputated it
so the hemostatic agents that are out
there they've gotten better now but at
the time it was you know you have to
hold pressure for five minutes otherwise
maybe the clot will break and then now
he's gonna bleed inside there and you'll
never see it so I'm sorry yelling at
somebody get a tourniquet on him they do
and you know he's just stacked up you
know taking a more more real estate for
us so her team sergeant Scott he's
trying to figure out okay now we have
you know another casualty so we we
headed another negative and we lost out
of a positive can now it's that's a dude
who can't help move and so at that point
he's very I know at this point it's very
clear we're didn't we're done with the
mountain we just need to go home so
we're still still working him I know I
know I was working on on Dylan and Scott
ends up getting shot for the first time
in the chest plate and so I run over to
him at this point check him
you know hesitates say he's fine but
he's fine
the chess play did its job he's he's
obviously gonna feel that for a few days
so I go back keep trying to package up
these guys a little bit more and we're
just you know it's it's tough not to
gloss over like minor wounds like you
know this guy just got more shrapnel
wounds like quick check
you're fine move on one of our commandos
at some point in all of this another one
of our commandos got shot in the head
and he dropped instantly I that dudes a
hundred percent dead but later was pull
him back over and like he's actually
still alive years he just decided to
take a little nap out there on the edge
of the honey a minute but it you know it
there's weird things bullets do it
dented the his head but it didn't kill
him so we're just you know continuing
just accumulate these problems and so
working Scott ends up turning around to
say something to us and that's when he
got shot again this time in the left arm
and almost amputate says left arm but
not nothing compared to the visual image
that Johnson had and I think it was the
same bullet was it bullet right after on
a burst I can't say for sure but it was
at the same time that he got shot on the
left arm I got hit in the head and so
I'd had my helmet back on at this point
so I got hit in the head and so working
on Dylan and I'm you know trying to ask
him like am i all right like I I don't
know but you know trying to do it but
sweeps are trying to figure out they
have so much blood donor Monteux
everywhere I don't know if I'm bleeding
so I'm asking
you know I'm asking him I'm working on
like how am I am i okay can I can I keep
going but he's like yeah you're you're
fine I don't know remember exactly what
he said but it conveyed yeah you're fine
so I grab a jar here just a flesh wound
yeah look I mean the helmet the helmet
did its job so it wasn't wasn't didn't
do anything to me it felt like I got hit
with a baseball bat like just how I
described it feels like what you would
think it would so I grab a tourniquet
run out to Scott put a tourniquet on his
his left arm there's just your fall
there's nowhere to put people luckily
he's of the serious injuries we were
human he's the only ambulatory guy so
they said he's self evacuates down the
same side of the mountain that we had
come up and you know where the fire was
continued to get worse but there was
there was some guys at Howard and Matt
Williams they're doing good work over
there and so basically he kind of got
down there and they see him with his arm
and they're like we'll get you we'll get
you taken care of so they worked him
down down the mountain on that one side
but that really only only worked for him
because he could move everybody else is
not that mobile so Dave Sanders is kind
of coming through and you know he's he's
trying to figure out a route for us and
so in in my mind like what I just
consider he behind me now there's
basically the cliff kind of just goes
straight down but like any cliff there's
there's a little terrace over here it
was a little terraced over there so he
he's exploring that route and he comes
back up and it just comes to the simple
like he's like this will work and we're
like is everybody gonna can these guys
do it and he's like they probably won't
die
well that's it's better than where we're
at right now that's that's a good plan
so yeah hey I got this one section of
one other article I pulled out this is
it it's somewhere around here and again
it's it's like but I just this this left
a really good picture in my mind of what
was going on and kind of the the how
critical the situation is Walton captain
Walton was the was the element commander
he's the the and he this is this is
talking about him and he's got some
quotes in here but this is from the
Stars and Stripes which is like a
military newspaper overseas and it says
Walton feared his force was on the verge
of being overrun with the insurgents
nearing his position Walton reached
fergan aid and called in a massive
danger-close strike expecting it could
take out his entire team they were all
prepared to make the ultimate sacrifice
he said the bomb dropped and then he saw
an image he would remember forever from
that fight sure's body draped over the
injured men he'd been working on through
the fight in that moment the strike that
we had called in on our own position
detonated just above us and blocked out
the Sun as the dust settled Ron sure was
the first thing that I saw on top of his
wounded teammates protecting them even
to the end when we had all fully
accepted that we were going to go down
fighting
Ron sure was still thinking of others
yeah like I mean like he says in there
it definitely it definitely got to the
point where like okay this is this is
the day oh I don't know how everybody
kind of just process that I know for me
there was a point where I just said a
quick prayer just passing god help my
wife Miranda and our our son who at the
time was a couple days shy of three
months old just make sure they're cool
with with what's about to happen and
then just go back to work and just you
know taking it in little chunks it's
it's too big to try and think of we go
over the course the day I made the for
us critical three other us wounded to
kaa about 13 14 15 Afghan commandos
interpreters wounded and so it you know
in just terms of those numbers that's
it's too much to deal with but if I just
you know this is the worst thing and
going on right now I'm gonna deal with
this and then come up for air or look
around that's that's now the worst thing
so I'm going over there I'm gonna deal
with that and so you know just keep
taking it on little chunks keep working
working through it and at some point you
started working towards okay we got to
get these guys down we're gonna start
lowering these guys down so Dave Sanders
figure it out okay this is this is the
least bad option so I just started
getting everybody you're ready to go
kind of started with everything of these
guys who were up here Lewis has a really
bad injury but
he's stable enough I gave him a fentanyl
lollipop so he he's not feeling too bad
like you're going first so we got him I
just do a double check on on the guy and
then go over to you begin the edge of
the cliff and start working them down as
and depending on how bad their their
wound was like Louise could help himself
a lot so like I'll just get him ready
get him over the edge and Dave and why
am I forgetting our combat camera guys
named Mike Carter they'd kind of take
him the rest the way down the hill and
then I'd go back up to our position all
right next serious one was Dylan okay
getting him ready yet I mean I got an IV
he started on him got a few different
things going I got everything as ready
as they could send him over
all that stuff was ripped out and just
mangled by the time I got into the
bottom but well it is what it is
that's now what were the with later so
then it came time to got over to John
Wall Dean started doing an assessment on
him just through the variances of battle
and and everything his his tourniquet
had been placed properly it which his
vessels sometimes will relax or
attention or tense up just so he was at
that point he's actually bleeding quite
profusely so we had to make some
adjustments on his tourniquet get him
restabilized
just had him hold his leg just give him
something to do and you know we start
lowering him down the hill and as we're
we're kind of finishing that up make all
of the ambulatory commando and
interpreter casualties they're kind of
working their way down through all this
as well
Seth Howard and Matt Williams are kind
of mentioned earlier like they came
through right behind us just kicking off
everybody else that hadn't got the
message it was time to go or like CK you
would you know been killed they got they
got him off for us the the Afghan
commando we you know just didn't really
have a great plan for we got him off and
we just got everybody down started
setting up another casualty collection
point down there at the bottom of the
hill
you know hallway you're climbing down
and stuff still exploding you're still
getting shot at but by the time I got
down to the the valley again it was a
little bit more covered it was you know
everything that day was just this sucks
less than that so I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do this so at that point you know got
everybody off it got to go through
recheck everybody now because we've now
moved moved all the patients long since
out of most of my supplies so then it
comes down to well you do need a bandage
but he needs it more but you're you're
gonna be fine without one and just kind
of keep making those calls how long did
it take for Kaiser vac to show up so
we'd never really got like a dedicated
two calves back to come in that day we
had some Blackhawks that were supporting
the mission up there and those pilots
were awesome they're like there's
wounded we're gonna come in it's hot
they're fine with it they know what's
going on so they came in and we got the
first group loaded up and out him in
they came in again got the next group so
basically we got all the critical and
all the non-ambulatory people out of
there and then everybody else just you
you just got a walk out of here
there's no nothing else going to come
for you it was at some point around this
time when I'm down down in the valley
working at that point that can notice my
arm is starting to hurt a little bit and
they just look at my arm arms there it's
fine whatever just you know if you bang
your elbow on something you just gonna
shake it out and you move on with your
day it was later that night you know get
back to the base after we went and saw
the wounded guys go take a shower I
noticed I had cut on my arm and bruising
around my elbow well that wasn't there
earlier went found my uniform and it's
got that bullet hole in it and I was
like oh I don't have any idea but so
important herb around when when that
went through
yeah just is one of those days like as
bad as it was you know you you just an
inch this way I mean I think we'd done
the math before and it was like we came
up with like eight inches or something
for the enemy he just could move a
bullet eight inches over the course of
the day like move this bullet one inch
this way move this bullet or this way
they you know would have just killed
everybody like one of the guys got shot
through the his Camelback you know it
burst that it hit like he had a flare
and the bacteria had done that but that
you just in inch that Dylan who had the
bullet skin between his armor and his
his gary moved that
but that's how combat is you know
millimeters and inches you you train you
you get it's good and proficient as you
can and then hope for a little bit a
little bit of luck as well you you guys
and you I know you lost - well you lost
your one interpreter killed well CJ and
then one Afghan soldier killed yeah but
none of the Americans were were killed
no none of the Americans that's like
completely you know that's a miracle
it's incredible yeah Bob Barra Dean he
was the Afghan first sergeant he was on
that SF team knows when the blocking
down Valley at some point they came up
to kind of help us do that final
policing up of everything and he was he
was he was a great first harder for them
he was leading from the front like he
should and he caught around just below
that chest plate it is a your order is a
vena cava it doesn't much matter but he
dropped and that was it so as as rough
as the day was and as much as you kind
of go through after the fact like what
could I have done better wasn't good you
know been here a little faster than that
shot that guy a little bit quicker the
only two okay there was just there's
nothing to be done for so I eventually
got comfortable with it all because of
that and then what when your team what
did they even do with your team now you
guys come back you got all these
casualties that they stand you guys down
they send you home what they do with you
know we so after we got everybody all
the the wounded guys out eventually we
kind of regroup we go down back back to
the NFL point get them the helicopters
leave wind up landing at some fire base
I don't even know where
was we don't know if we're going back
there's another SF team there we still
got a lot of commandos mm-hmm so we're
like back in the gun are we gonna go I
linked up with the medical support that
was there refit my bag got got
everything ready to go again like we
were gonna go right back
but we didn't which was probably the
right call for that day so then we ended
up going back to Jalalabad which is
where we were operating out of at the
time a couple of the wounded guys were
there so we went and saw them a couple
of the wind guys were already at Bagram
we took care of them we got a that
senior you know let's the guy Carl
became our new acting team sergeant
we just went about better day I mean we
still we still did an another mission
few weeks later it's just funny remember
so one of the one of the guys I dan
plants he's now sergeant major out there
that was his his first mission with us
and of course he's like are they all
like this and of course they are some of
them are worse welcome aboard
yeah everybody get some doing and then
how much longer was that deployment you
guys did a few more operations is with
your new team sergeant you guys want how
did you feel going back out obviously
that that fight was was different than
anything we'd faced before
you know that when when we left whatever
it was six weeks later that was my last
comment deployment so I didn't face
anything like that again but it was well
we went back out I mean we're ready to
go again
and I remember on that that next mission
we went out on we're going through the
village and our interpreters are just
yeah they would talk with a bad guys on
walkie-talkies sometimes they just talk
talk shit back and forth to each other
and so at one point they were like oh
these were the guys that we just I think
these are the guys we just messed up a
few weeks ago like let's get them and
then a Kiowa came in and did a run and
took out a few and they're like second
thought let's let's call today I you
know I draw and that was that was the
end of that day but so yeah I mean it
was definitely a day we'll never forget
and but I'm just glad that you know the
team came together they got the job done
we didn't accomplish the mission we
didn't find the bad guy we didn't get to
bring him back but you know some days
the win is he's just we got everybody
that we could out of there alive and you
know we certainly gave him worse than we
got yeah estimated enemy killed was like
150 to 200 and and that that that ended
up being the most decorations highest
decorations handed out for a single day
battle since the Vietnam War was for
this for this operation that you guys
went on and then so when you came home
what made you decide because you ended
up getting out of the army what made you
decide you're gonna get out I ended up
getting out may of 2009 so just over a
year later it was a lot of different
factors like said my my older son was
actually born in January of 2008 so I
came home saw him born and then went
right back to Afghanistan and you know
we had other missions in this mission
afterwards so that you know that
priority factor start starts to go in
there another part of it was just I
think I always felt like there was
something I was supposed to do and that
seemed like as good a good a thing to
check a block with this as I could I
could think of I don't know it's so many
different like factors yeah I mean that
like I there's not a day that goes by
that I don't still miss the team is so
wish whenever I hear they're out there
like I wish I was there with them I wish
I was you know still doing it but you
know I felt like I'd done whatever it
was I was supposed to do and you know I
think I get stuff for any special
operations guy CEO Green Beret right or
whatever at some point you have to hang
it up because time is going to yeah it's
a young man gonna hang it up whether you
want to or not at some point it's it
it's that game so I felt like I mean
I'll go out on my own terms
first big yeah and then how did you end
up getting into the Secret Service like
what what made you look at that and
think that seemed like a good call so I
think I started applying for them when I
had about six months ago in in the
middle to keep your interest on them so
full disclosure within my federal law
enforcement just seemed like a good next
transition so I
shotgun blast out you know the FBI the
Secret Service that he a marshals air
marshals everybody
and very quickly on I really just like
the personality that came with the
Secret Service the the attitude that the
people had the dedication of the job the
focus in a lot of ways you know like
like SF like you have super important
mission sometimes you have all the
resources you need sometimes you don't
you're still going to figure it out
you're still going to you're still going
to make it work I really like that
personality that came with it so while
everybody showed interest in me I kind
of focused there and I'm getting hired
them a couple months after I got got out
of the army and then what's that
onboarding like you go through like a
bootcamp scenario with them because they
must take kids out of college right
you're supposed to have like a remember
what the book answer is like three years
of real-world experience after college
okay so from my class you had a mixture
some people had military background some
people had law enforcement backgrounds
some had one was a lawyer just any
different background so is it like a
gentlemen's course boot camp scenario
for the most part you know coming from
from the SF background like I don't know
who we need to kick out you gotta kick
out somebody right just to make sure
that everybody else who's here know it
was like yeah it could happen to you but
I we had a good class so everybody
everybody got through and but it was
mostly was about three months of
training in Georgia at the federal law
enforcement training center kind of
basic information it's a criminal
investigator training programs and
basically legals law stuff how to handle
evidence all that kind of stuff the
basics every law enforcement person
needs and then you continue on with four
more months at the Secret Service where
you learn
the the two aspects of of our agency
both the financial crimes investigations
and the protection aspect the most
people don't know about the financial
crimes investigation of the Secret
Service
I don't think about that arm of it well
and that's I mean that's why it was
created you know President Lincoln
signed the Secret Service into into
existence to fight counterfeiting
because at the end of the Civil War by
camera more the statistic like
two-thirds of the currency in the
country was counterfeit and you can't
rebuild when half of everything is fake
so he you know he signed that and it was
soon after that you know he went to a
play didn't work out for him but then it
was 40 years later that we kind of took
over the full-time protection of the
President and of course that's our our
main mission now well while the majority
of people in the agency are are out
there keeping the financial system
secured intact
obviously the number one mission is the
president of the vice president's other
heads of state or has government that
come in to the country we protect them
and you know obviously they're all no
failed missions like you cannot let
something happen to the president or if
you have some country come in that maybe
nobody's you know nobody's ever heard of
this dude well we still can't let random
street violence happen to this guy or or
something so you just there's that whole
spectrum that you have to work around so
you get done with the training and then
where did you what was your where did
you get stationed did you go to the
president's detail or did you go to the
crime fighting partner
so the typical career path is as you go
out to one of the field offices around
the country and fight crime for a little
while so when I got got the offer
they offered me a couple different
cities to start in
Phoenix Arizona sound like the best
option so I took that yeah my wife and
son moved out there right away we bought
a house you know while I take me to live
there I was off at training for several
months and then join them as soon as I
finished up and I spent basically the
next four years in Phoenix from May 2010
to May 2014 doing whatever financial
crime work includes what yeah yeah your
credit card fraud your counterfeiting I
need to get your number cookie credit
card fraud people are all about you know
coming after me they dig they open
access and that's what and and when I
talk to people like yeah that happens
it's happened to everyone that's like
the main crime right now when I say hey
there's credit card fraud of me says you
know that happened to me two weeks ago
it's happening to everyone it yeah it's
happened to me it happens okay maybe I
won't call you it's it's one of those
things I mean there's so many different
levels to it like you can you know
there's the prudence thing you know
you'll see the things like oh check a
ATM to see if you see a skimmer attached
to it which is great advice it's
definitely something you know something
looks weird on the ATM so use it but you
go to a store and I mean even like
Target or these bigger stores oh yeah
that's right they had the bastard you
get hacked you didn't do anything wrong
like you use the Machine machine was
secure you thought but at some back
level so there's those two aspects of
the crime that we know cheese next is
the person who stole all the the card
information but they're almost never the
person who's using it they sell it to
somebody else so you you've got to pick
which side do I want to chase today
don't wanna figure out who stole it oh
and figure out who's using it and it
can't be pretty busy and then eventually
you get called back to
DC is that where you got stationed next
so I'm stationed in DC now with the
counter-assault team for the Secret
Service
it's which is like the cool like the
coolest job right I mean in the Secret
Service let's be straight up right
there's nothing cooler than saying I'm
on the counter assault team of the
Secret Service
it does sound cool yes and what it
really means is sitting in the back of a
vehicle somewhere for long periods of
time in a motorcade or something yeah
with the full body armor on the other
thing so you're uncomfortable you're
miserable complaining about it like why
did I sign up for this but and there's
like eight thousand pieces of security
that someone would have to get overcome
for you guys to get the call but some
day it does sound cool so we got that
going for us
but what I love about that just like
with SF is you know to be there you have
to you have to volunteer you have to go
through a selection process you had to
go through another school we washed out
between selection and the school itself
wash out about half maybe a little more
how tighter they get are they on
shooting in that school standards are
much higher than the general Secret
Service could you might be taking shots
around the president you don't want to
throw that round you know no pressure
yeah it adds a little extra level to
that you know law enforcement every
round counts aspects up to the military
you know most rounds most most most
rounds count you can't just fire
indiscriminately but you know if he's
generally in that area that's why they
gave me more than one bullet yeah Secret
Service yeah I got I got in trouble one
time during during CQC training for
putting down cover fire in a building
yeah I was like you know someone's
trying to cross the hallway I'm like
okay I know there's a bad guy other
misters are shooting at him and um you
know the instructor is like choco what
were you doing over here I was like
where he's like in this you know you're
holding this hallway and then you just
started shooting and I was like oh let's
put it down cover fire for the guy those
movie goes he's think I get it but
you're really not supposed to do that in
CQC and I'm like okay fair enough you
know but if the guy Morgan I don't work
yeah he wasn't coming around the corner
when I was cracking rounds at him so
you're so you and so you're just that's
do you go on
is there a rotation that you're going on
for that are you like on all the time
pretty three months on three months off
do you just are you just in a certain
area and that's when you're live so they
break us down into we call them we have
teams and then two teams make up a
company and then and then so we have
basically four different elements so
ones on training ones on your days ones
on your evening ones on your your meds
at all time and so yeah your downtime is
to train and then the rest of the time
you're up protecting protecting the man
or you know president vice president
other people as as need support
just always working and at some point
during during that job you you got you
you went to the hospital and figured out
something that wasn't going to well it
stayed at least so you know if you kind
of go through the the full story here
was that late spring early summer of
2016 I just kinda started getting a
little pain in my my right hip a little
pain in my back
but of course I have some pain I was
running around a kit for the army for
six and a half years you know at that
point I've been doing it with the
counter assault team for two and a half
years just you know you're not supposed
to do that to your body it's not it's
not good for you everybody knows it
so I was actually in California hiking
with the Obama family and Yosemite doing
a Father's Day weekend trip with them
and you know my hip was hurting back
kind of seized up no this is this is not
right but I go see my dog he's like just
stretched some more like or stop doing
your your
well I'm not gonna stop so I'm gonna
stretch some more ain't all kind of guy
kept getting a little worse little you
know just a little more annoying as as I
went
since the doc didn't give me a good
answer let me try a chiropractor got
some relief for a little while from that
and it but it just kept getting getting
a little bit worse and so he came up
with the the differential diagnosis to
use a medical terms that he was like you
probably tore some cartilage in your hip
at some point I was like I don't
remember doing that he's like well as
active as you are I can just happen
sometimes so we do an MRI in February of
2017 and then then next day waiting on
results is still flat I actually flew
out to San Diego to do to do some more
work and that afternoon after I got here
he called and he was you know telling us
well yeah a few different use the word
lesions you don't want to say tumors but
he's like you got a few things going on
your hip that are not normal I need you
to go talk to this doc like as soon as
you can he didn't uh didn't even tell me
like what the what that doc did but like
okay he's at this hospital he's this doc
i google him like anybody wouldn't like
he's an oncologist like so this like of
course that call is bad but you know now
we're getting more information okay
really not good
I took the red-eye back home and next
day I get a cat scan and that's when
they find tumors just everywhere what
they decided was the the primary tumor
was about the size of a little bigger
than a baseball in my left lung and by
that point I started thinking like with
all the work that I've been doing like
I'm just getting out of shape like my
runtimes keep you in a little worse but
no point did I think that's what it was
so we find out like through that MRI
like I'd actually I had a fracture on my
pelvis
she had a baseball on my lung and a
fractured my pelvis and still working so
yeah we go through the process of trying
to you know figure out what's going on
find a doc don't really care for him
fire him
go find another doc in Johns Hopkins we
really like we're still working with him
yeah we've been fighting just over two
years now and then on top of that your
your well as I mentioned you guys your
ODA team got something like I don't know
12 or 13 silver stars amongst them just
10 silver stars three or four bronze
though the Air Force cross for the US
and you were one of those you were one
of those silver stars SMS and they the
the government or yeah the military
basically Africa what year is maybe 2015
or 16 they started doing a service wide
review of all of the awards that had
been handed out or awarded to see if
they all all kind of matched up and were
where they should be and I know actually
a three of my guys who had been written
up for Bronze Stars they got they got
advanced or they got raised two silver
stars but they reviewed year award as
well and they came to a conclusion that
it should be upgraded and how did you
find out about that
so I of course had heard about the
review process that the Secretary of
Defense had ordered never gave it a
second thought just was going about my
my day-to-day life I mean honestly I
think like most soft guys like just a
attaboy and uh here's your next mission
that's all any of them expect or want or
or anything so in August of last year I
get the first call on on my home phone
you know you still have a what so that's
part of that triple play package you
know they get you with the home phone
like I don't want a home phone they're
like because more to not have it like
the landline yeah yeah so somebody
somebody calls they left haven't they
left a voicemail on that even call a
voicemail when it's on the answering
machine I don't know they they called
and left a message and they claimed that
they were from the Pentagon and they
they said we needed to talk to Ron sure
this is it almost sounds legit but it's
definitely a scam I'll call him back and
just speaking of credit card fraud here
we go so I call him up and they're like
we need to set up a call between you and
a hiring and EOD official and I'm like
whoo-hoo like we can't tell you I'm like
why we can't tell you well that doesn't
sound right so go to send me an email
from your official dot dot mil to my
secret service email launched it over
there we'll just just to verify who you
are cuz you say you're from the Army
here at the Pentagon you're doing I get
calls from them all the time you know
the IRS is always calling me saying I'm
about to be arrested
so they sent me the message confirming
who they were and so like she's not
gonna tell me why and they're like no
well that's cool I got a family vacation
I'm taking next week I have this person
call me after that but like I'd
mentioned where we're in this cancer
battle and so just before we went on
that trip I started getting some new
pain so we do some scans we find out I
got a little bit and a little bit of
stuff don't groan when we make a plan to
deal with that as soon as we get back
from our trip so I go on my family
vacation we come back and we start
radiation basically the next day just
trying to get control again so this
person and the army they start calling
me yeah I'm like hey we're gonna set up
a date for this person to talk to you
it's like okay cool do you have any idea
right now or you just know we my wife
and I we're trying to like brainstorm
like I knew about the review process did
that even click in your head I think at
one point so with the the email like the
the not subtly but like your name and
then this is my job is so important I am
signature signature like that I see that
and I see what it is so I google that
cuz I don't know who this person is
already investigator view so I started
going down that chain and at one point
we actually found out that it there in
the long process of the Medal of Honor
they're they're one of the many tears
but when I kind of look at each other
you know just kind of chuckle it off
like that's ridiculous but so we're like
well maybe maybe you know I got a
witness for somebody I got a witness for
something
I signed up for the you know the burn
pit registry that's out there like sign
up for that at all maybe it's something
do any of these numerous things so the
data I'm supposed to get the call I'm
telling that day because might just
finished up some radiation feel awful
and so I get the first call from the
military saying are you gonna take your
call later today like yes I'm good then
one of my friends ends up calling
Miranda and says basically stand by for
Ron's boss and so he gets on the line to
talk to Miranda and he's like it's Ron
good for a phone call today and it's
just like yes Ron's fine for a call he's
just the call that we've been talking to
other people about it and he's like yeah
you know why are you calling we we just
can't process like why is he now calling
us so he's like are you good for your
call like yeah we're good for a call the
army calls me back again you good for
your call like yes I'm still good for my
call I'm gonna run out of battery you
know if you people keep calling me the
check if my good for my my call or not
so a little while later my boss calls
back again and he's like your call is
cancelled like why are you canceling my
call and you know just trying to run
through all the scenarios in your head
like why are you doing anything with
this and he's like trust me it's good
and I was like I don't trust you but but
okay I have no choice in this matter so
he ends up calling and he's saying next
Tuesday I need you to come into the
White House with with Miranda and you
need to talk to the boss of the
president's detail that makes even less
sense than anything that's been
happening so far
so Tuesday it's September 4th wind-up he
comes by our house gets us brings us in
into the White House complex and we go
over and we start him the boss of the
president's detail we start off in his
office and so he meets us in there he's
like you know hi Ron I'm Miranda thanks
for coming in really appreciate it
John Kelly wants to talk to you guys
so of course Miranda and I are kind of
looking at each other like trying to do
like has he knows like in kind of where
we we landed is like okay I think I'm
gonna get upgraded to across which is
amazing honor I think and I think the
Secret Service found out and since John
Kelly the chief us out at the time you
know
former general we have that connection
like he's gonna he's gonna bring me in
to tell me so we we spend some time in
that that boss's office and they bring
us into the waiting room and in the West
Wing itself and sort of sitting there
just continuing to wait and then John
Kelly comes by and he's like hey Ron hey
Miranda I thanks so much for coming in I
just want to talk with you guys for a
little bit and so it's like follow me
back to my office
so we start follows so we started
following him down Miranda doesn't know
the White House so she's just tagging
along like we're walking down the
hallway and I think I could pass sir
Huckabee's office and she's like oh look
like just you know he's getting kind of
starstruck by the by the office and all
the things but in my mind I'm like you
know I don't want to interrupt the chief
of staff to the president but like sir
your office is is that way like do you
know where you work
but I'm just along for the ride
so walk down the hall we make a couple
turns and then he makes that left into
what I know is the OL and so I get to
that threshold I see the president
sitting at his desk and as soon as I hit
that threshold I can see there's cameras
so the video and your still camera is
just going crazy just White House
internal stuff just clicking away and at
that point it was definitely like you
know oh shit did NACO today kind of got
out of hand so the president gets up he
shakes her hand you know he did not
expect to see me today did you know I
wasn't I wasn't planning on it
- they can't remember everything you
know just the usual platitudes thanks
for your service heard you were in
Afghanistan like yeah and he's like did
you know you're getting looked at for
Afghanistan no he's like well I just
want you to know I just approved you get
the Congressional Medal of Honor and
honestly at that point it all kind of
went to white noise I couldn't I don't
know what else he said afterwards we
have the pictures and you can you can
flip through and you can see the moment
where he tells because I have a definite
what the are you saying and my wife is
starting kind of that happy you're happy
cry but yeah so we had had no no idea
that I was getting I mean I knew
generally things were getting looked up
but I'm no idea that my packet would
stand out or not stand out or or
anything yeah we got out of there the
the the boss that had basically found
out it was you know government
efficiencies like that day ever supposed
to get the call they kind of went down
the hall like does this guy work for you
like
I've been emailing you from a Secret
Service email address for weeks now but
so it was at that moment they're like
does he work for you and they're like
yeah he works for us and he's here in DC
and he he has a White House pass he can
walk in a little white house anytime he
wants so so they coordinated that they
made sure the counter assault team for
that day they were all weird you know
marine a green beret some more army and
marine just army guys who all kind of
got it and then they found out like as I
was finding out and so went and saw them
and yeah the whole whole thing was just
super surreal trying to figure out why
me why why not why any of it remember
he's soon after that the the colonel
from the Pentagon she called she's like
so you've obviously now talked to him
you know you you know why we were being
secretive now and like yeah and then she
said a lot of stuff about like you know
how the process is gonna work and and
other things and at the end of it it got
to the point I was like ma'am I don't
remember a thing you just said but I
don't have a uniform and like I don't
know why that out for seven eight nine
years or something age thousand nine is
when I got out so this is me that's nine
and a half years
yeah next month will be ten so it was
not a half year since I got out so yeah
it was the last thing that I thought was
was coming I mean I'm obviously super
humbled by by it but it was definitely
last thing I thought would come my way
I still remember feeling almost guilty
calling my teammates to let them know so
like hey can you can you come to DC on
October 1st cuz I'm getting about a
lottery like probably had to apologize
to them like
the team was amazing that day the team
did everything and a lot of these guys
you know kept going for years and years
after I got out like I don't know why
I'm getting this it's awesome I'm sure
they all thought to themselves well that
maybe the fact that you saved my life
and kept me alive
might be the reason so yeah that's
unbelievable awesome story and it sounds
like there was definitely some good
smooth government operating in there as
well in the end they weren't they worked
out it worked out to be pretty good
secret yeah pretty awesome that they
kept it from you hey captain you know
after we stepped out of the Oval John
Kelly is like sorry I had to pull a
trick on you okay yeah he's like such an
honest guy that he felt guilty about
that yeah like such a good guys I am
really sorry that it's okay I forgive
you
and then how when you go talking about
the cancer a little but when you go in
for radiation when you go in for chemo
like I know people have gone on chemo
before
it's like crushing physically so with
with my treatments we're in a
reassessment phase right now to figure
out what we're doing but the last couple
years I've been on it's a okay it's
super far out in the weeds but it's a
targeted therapy for my for my very
specific kind of lung cancer and so I
take one pill every day and you know
it's got me two years down the road so
it the there's ups and downs with it
some you know definitely some side
effects I think generally speaking it's
better than what you think of is chemo
or I know it's pissed off a lot of
keyboard warriors and sergeant majors
out there in the world like I didn't
shave for the for the ceremony and I was
like because I had a rash from from my
treatment so I physically couldn't shave
at the time but some people took offense
like sorry I really I I want it was you
know that's awesome
that's only in America could you say oh
that guy got the Medal of Honor you
might want to shave next time that's
that's professional jealousy at its
finest right yeah and so I baby trying
to chase down too many people but a few
of them in like oh just so you know like
this is why I have a nice day I mean
what are you doing day-to-day now so are
you still do you where are you working
right now Secret Service you have to put
any time with them or you on like some
medical leave right now did you stay in
the Secret Service
yeah I'm still still with the Secret
Service some a few people have asked me
not what the matter like its Secret
Service just a cover when I was talking
my wife you know my wife has been
talking to your wife and I said
something along the lines of like oh you
know we'll talk about you know using the
secret cities in the Secret Service and
my wife said and my wife said Britt so
she doesn't like fully comprehend
American government like an American
does but you know I said you know we
probably talked about you know he made
in the Secret Service and my wife of
course literally says but isn't that a
secret
so yeah could cover a cover for your
covert operations that you're now
conducting yeah yeah no it's yeah so
once I once I was diagnosed a couple
years ago I just switched over from
being operational counter assaults you
when I'm gonna say operations yeah but
now I'm in the Operations Section
got it yeah so I just send emails to
people and I'm I'm a keyboard warrior
myself now like you were not working
hard enough for Carter's
you might want to shave while you're
working harder by the way yeah and and
that's and then you got your wife and
your kids and how old your kids our boys
are older son Cameron who because it was
was three months at the time of the
battle he's he's 11 now and our younger
son Tyler he's he's eight so you know my
wife has you know multiple full-time
jobs you tryna keep those kids you know
where they need to be when they need to
be there like with the Secret Service I
can't remember the exact day count but
the last year I was like fully able to
travel in everything I travel like 130
days or something and you know at least
I like the military time deployments
like you're gonna leave in August like
okay that's in the future I know when it
is you're gonna be gone for seven months
whereas you know the Secret Service work
depended on people I mean does the
president want to go over here if he
does we're going guess what it doesn't
matter what we had scheduled next week
it's going to happen so you know in the
hundred thirty days on sound that bad
it's two days here three days there a
call at 8:00 p.m. tomorrow morning
you're on a plane at 6 a.m.
get packed so you know she's been she
was amazing at balancing all of those
things that came came with a job and
then then I threw in a monkey wrench
with the hole I have cancer everywhere
make it more about me now so it cuz the
kids were what was that kindergarten in
third grade I think we're the ages I
diagnosed like they were just starting
to get a little bit easier and you know
she's kind of come out for air like hold
on I need didn't challenge you a little
more sorry about that
well it's you know sounds like an I met
her today seems like awesome awesome
woman awesome family and um I mean a
just incredible story from for
everything that you've done and what
you've been through what you're going
through and the perseverance that you're
shown is just perseverance that you
showed and the perseverance that you
continue to show is just it's awesome
man and probably good probably good
Polly has good a place of any to try and
wrap this up but you know man
thanks for coming on and and really
thanks for thanks for giving an example
to everyone of you know how to how to
train how to fight and how to live it's
uh it's awesome why appreciate you
saying that and yeah I'm not just you
know say this cuz I'm on your show like
I've been listening to your your podcast
for a long time I I've listened to many
different episodes but there's one in
particular where you you know you do the
book reviews and the a man's search for
meaning you did that one I think two or
three months after I had diagnosed and
that was I mean I like to think I'm a
determined guy and like I can focus
through stuff but you know the cancer
battle is definitely very different than
an army battle like again we get
discussed earlier like if you can shoot
me I could show you
we'll see this is that kind of behind
the scenes unknown enemy and so just you
know hearing about like that book and
then I immediately went out and got the
book read it like just stuff so you know
your podcast is definitely you know not
only on those long boring nights we
can't sleep is this this hurts and that
hurts like something to listen to but
it's definitely been very meaningful to
me and in those respect so I really
appreciate it and hopefully hopefully
with someone hurt you know interesting
today oh man no it's it's awesome and
we'll we'll keep doing it echo is
speaking of the podcast speaking of
you know taking the fight to the enemy
have seen and unseen sure yeah big time
I know you like to you know give us some
ideas some some help along the combative
yeah I have a question first
okay someone you got hit in the arm that
time that you didn't realize it or
whatever like what was that like a
ricochet or something does the bullet
dude yeah but like what was you know
what happened with it
oh you mean it's the tiniest little scar
you could barely see it like there like
a like it just barely grazed you kind of
thing yeah i grazed to me when i when i
got the uniform off I mean there was
there was there was cut there was a
bleeding there was bruising like I said
it couldn't cuz it's the pain so much
stuff is going on that like boom yeah
you get hit but then it kind of gets
blended in with all the all the rest of
the chaos kind of thing yeah I mean so
much wet with the the air strikes of
snow that we've been talking about like
yeah stop was stop was just hitting you
falling on yourself was it was just
stuff was always going on so yeah I was
it shot yeah yeah I you know what else
is crazy is that I just you know echoing
doesn't ever write anything down during
these things and you've made that
statement like probably like 45 minutes
ago but echoes has been sitting there
thinking like dang what happened yeah
well can we expand on that comes I got
that question I'm coming at you wrong
well yeah you sort of wonder cuz you
just sort of mentioned it you know like
oh kind of like on your brought
Terminator one the first one where they
kind of recover from the shootout and
then there under the bridge and then in
think that she started kind of goes hey
like what's up you know he was oh yeah
he got me right there
he just sort of glosses over she's like
you got shot like oh what's up that's
how I was feeling with you you know I'm
saying well luckily it was didya shot
but luckily you know for my sake and for
we other people just not knowing when it
was yeah it wasn't worse cuz let me keep
keep going about
about about the job yeah it's crazy now
Noah meters in inches inches but yeah so
yeah if we're staying on the path
speaking the winch okay let's start with
origin fortune up in Maine American made
company American founded company just an
American company I think there it sums
it up yeah but they go deep with the
American made though that's the thing
true so anyway so you're doing jiu-jitsu
which we all are you want Aggie you get
it from origin all made in America
nuki out by the way out a real good on
have you used it yeah yeah I know you're
kind of off did you get see for a little
bit yeah yeah I got a little uh got a
little dinged up in the knee there yeah
but you used it yes good assessment
solid legit as we sent yeah yeah yeah
also rash guards on there even though
you the existing G's are good are
exceptional actually they're the best in
the world actually made by jiu-jitsu
people in America with american-made
products how much here at is did you do
how much rolling did you do we did we
did a fair amount and then at some point
like I mentioned one that duties are two
showed up and kind of reset the way we
were training we did a little less
rolling and he found some high just
outside Fort Bragg it was like I just
met in fights in I think he was from
Miami he's like I've been in fights in
Miami free for years and years he was
really good at it apparently so we did a
little less rolling with him cuz he you
know he kind of brought at the point
like with all the stuff you're carrying
if you end up on the ground that's not a
good day for you yeah well if you end up
on the ground and you better know what
you do even with all that stuff on yeah
so yeah we he kind of taught us a
different way you know fighting it if
you get on the ground
yeah get back up as clearly as you can
yeah that's I always say like the
primary the primary purpose of jiu-jitsu
in a self-defense situation is to get up
and get
nothing to put a triangle on him he
won't put some kind of a you know pull
car guard on the guy yeah that's not
smart
negative no and the other funny thing is
like I was you know I was talking about
you two being important and all that
stuff but it like in the SEAL Teams
people would get really into combatives
which is cool I'm down with being a
menace
I am totally into combative so I'm
totally into MMA and jiu-jitsu and
wrestling and boxing more tight and
whatever else I can find that is
effective but if you have a choice
between being really good at shooting
your guns and being really good at
unlocking people if you're in the if
you're in the military it's better to be
good at shooting your guns now luckily
I'm here to tell you you can get good at
both yes but err prioritize being able
to shoot really well yes well most of my
workouts now with with the whole cancer
thing or just walks but not maybe I'll
check out one of these keys and walk
around the oh we don't you lake and well
we're at all get your keys for your kids
too because your kids should be doing
jiu-jitsu that's for sure yes agree but
also on there have other apparel items
fashionable we all know you don't like
the word he doesn't like the concept I
get it but the fact remains Pete he
knows that Pete Roberts founder of
origin yeah it was a little bit of us
yes Pete my partner up in the up in
Maine he's got like a little he's got a
little fashion sense do a little
sprinkle is it which I have zero so
there's a contrast there yeah you know
yeah Pete we'll talk about color yeah
yeah as long as it's black yeah gray or
get it yeah so many ways anyway also
supplements what best kind of
supplements joint supplements apparently
when we were young we're about the same
age I've estimated when were you born
78 some turn 40 yeah so you're one year
younger than me nonetheless back when we
were young we thought what protein
supplements right create remember one
creatine Jesus it was like hell yeah
that's the creatine there's so much of
that stuff no as it turns Acula not even
as important not even nearly as
important
as joint supplements so jock of course
makes supplements Jocko joint warfare
for what anti-inflammatory stuff
glucosamine chondroitin super krill oil
krill oil very important for your joints
um keeps you in the game even at our age
I am just rippling up on Joanne warfare
right now to help the recovery process
of my knee
oh yeah men the joint where and the
krill oil combo whatever one you're
consistent on I mean you could stay
consistent so I get it
but I have experience with inconsistency
so when when I get consistent man it's
like you're on this like Road like you
get dinged up or whatever but like you
go it's like they heal up so quick and I
don't want to make like oh you're like
what's the kind of AD x-men guy who
heals Wolverine I'm not necessarily
saying you're like Wolverine but you
feel like you kind of are Wolverine like
you when you get you know how like me
anyway when I get hurt weird like ding
demonic ding how long am i out now you
know a week two weeks or whatever like
with this I like I don't even worry
about it just in the game just in the
game consistently taking it so I take it
is what I'm saying well since you
mentioned Wolverine I'll say that with
my you know SF and then cancer like we
spent more time my wife and I talking
about the possibility that that phone
call was somebody gonna enroll me in the
deadly conversation yeah giving it
everything you know yeah you might be a
good candidate for this new program
we're putting together my little my
little daughter she watches a those what
is it Avengers this so she watches that
have Wolverine in it uh uh no right no
thank you okay well she watches those
things but the other day and she's also
kind of culpable right cuz she's nine is
you can't shoot a bubble you know what I
mean and she's nine but the other day I
started to started this whole like thing
with her where I was kind of telling us
like yeah you know cuz I'm saying oh my
knee
I was like yo my Neely it'll heal up
quickly and I said then I said like I
got the little idea in my head of
something creative to play
to play sir and so I said like yeah you
know it's weird sweetie cuz whenever I
get injured it heals up really really
fast it's really weird it's always been
like that well not always ice and then I
started saying well you know one time
it's really weird but I had this weird
memory of like mmm when when I was in
the Navy and I went to the doctor and
then I didn't remember things for a
while and I remember like them putting
things in me and my eyes were so big she
was so stuck about another minute and
she thought I was because I started up
when you start on when something comes
from them right so it was her that said
like oh how long are you gonna be hurt
for so then she initiated a conversation
that gives me a massive advantage in
this trick I'm about to play because I'm
playing the trick based on on her
reality right yeah I like you just do
some really some trick toward some
conversation no it's part of what she's
asked me on you know I wasn't just
sitting there plotting on it yeah kind
of so that's kind of like you think how
you make like when you when you come up
with a plan or a correction to a plan or
whatever like how you lead people and so
you lead people to think that they made
the plans yes yes you just did that to
your daughter she's not by the way
practiced underhood yeah yeah yeah jack
unless elements monk as well additional
proteins I still don't neglect the
protein don't get it wrong I just find
the joint supplements to be somebody
asked me on Twitter if I was on growth
hormone or because of the way I looked I
said I was actually it was actually
supposed to be a derogatory comment
because it was one of those little clips
that someone put up with me talking
about something and and then someone
with the the shot brain it said then why
would I listen this guy who looks like
he's been on growth hormones no life
right and and I just replied back like
I've never been on any kind of growth
hormone
unless you count state can I have fun on
Twitter yeah that's how the last Twitter
is Twitter's I know you have Twitter I
don't use Twitter that much is it I'm
trying to try to get an Instagram thing
yeah Twitter just still doesn't make
sense my brain Instagram is also can be
fun but Twitter is basically just a
bunch of one-liners it's just a bunch of
one-liners that's all it is one-line
zingers and it's just 24 hours a day if
you want to sit there and make more
minors all day long you know that's what
you can do with that thing that's a good
way to put it it's just one line and
what's what's lame about it or good
about it depending on your perspective
is if you and I are having a
conversation and you say something and I
sing like I I hit it that took a little
quick thinking with Twitter you can
actually sit there and look at it for 12
min you could look up words even the
dictionary you wanted to and you could
say oh this is gonna be really weedy
hand it out you can do some research in
and then you can respond and for all
anyone knows you just looked at that and
just threw it out there so you just got
the notification yeah just saw it and
I'm just throwing out this advanced shot
back at you whereas the reality is
that's not what happened so it's a
really interesting now I will say
sometimes because you go onto Twitter
and I reply like a lot at once because I
don't sit there and look at Twitter all
the time so then I go back and I just
reply really fast so a lot of times I
will do things that are you know just
like mm-hm and occasionally I make
mistakes yeah you know there's someone
on Twitter called the there's a Twitter
thing called grammar police yeah what do
you what do you mean like in a row or
dominant it's an account okay I used and
I was an English major
Ronna know you're an economics guy spend
you're in the numbers on the letters so
I I put your and again I'm tweeting at a
forty seven tweets a minute miss boom
boom and I used your why oh you are
instead of why oh you are ' II
but apostrophe re yeah and so then
answer then up pops like probably an
hour later up pops grammar police oh
yeah and it says and it's it's really I
actually love the way they do it they
don't cook they don't they don't they're
not disparaging to you
they just say for your information you
used the wrong you're the proper you
know the proper grammar in this scenario
would have been to use
why are you apostrophe re thank you and
please correct yourself next time sign
cranberries and so I like the grammar
police that's a good account yeah so
it's an actual like account the camera
please
I got Percy it's not a bot somebody's
sorted well you may be on it maybe a bot
but it's a grammar police account you
can follow them I should probably follow
ground at least I'm going to what are
the pictures they share though just yes
yeah okay I mean I guess Instagram you
could just you they could have they
could have blown up a picture and the
image of my incorrect you know you see
Joe or it would just slide in the
comments good right because you wouldn't
really you need a picture for comment so
it'd be like true oh yeah you know II
think and then they just lied in the
comment but they should know that hurts
cuz like I was an English major sir yes
sir it's the only way you'll learn
though yeah there you go we gotta get
you some warrior kid milk for your kids
wrong do you do when you were a kid did
you ever drink strawberry Quik yes did
you like it no okay what about chocolate
quick yes did you like it yes okay there
you go well for me a strawberry Quik was
kind of like a big thing for me when I
was little fake strawberry flavors it's
so hit and miss yeah well either one if
you happen to like strawberry Quik
basically are this kids
protein drink tastes exactly like that
it's delicious oh it would be it's
delicious to me it wouldn't be delicious
to you I guess you'd spit it out I would
spit it out if you like
don't drink
so you'd be cool about it well your kids
hopefully they have better taste buds
than you well this stuff is amazing so
anyways that's where your kid Molk in
its doesn't have any sugar and it's
actually good free it's got protein and
vitamins and probiotics it's awesome so
anyways that's that also chocolate store
it's called Jaco store that's where you
can get apparel chocolate peril because
he's so fashionable yes well you know
you see the dichotomy in this and try
going there the thing is it's like it's
not even fashionable but here's the
thing I snuck I had to sneak in covertly
in insert elements sprinkles of fashion
okay be Robert style not quite that
hardcore but hardcore fast you know like
what is a Zoolander I'm like Zoolander
in your mind um so so Jacko's design
right it's like his thing it's like not
even design the font he uses is like
computer font literally none so it's
like OCR whatever so he's like you're at
this point it goes free no you know
we'll put it on the shirt I'm like cool
so I look at I'm like okay I dig it but
at least I made the shirt like the shirt
material is like you know a bland and
all this stuff it's not like some cheap
what do you call like a boxy uh rugged I
don't call it anything I call it a shirt
yeah see and that's my point right there
that's everything so the designs are
gonna be super basic non fashionable but
when you get the apparel you gonna be
like oh this is really wearable stuff is
really nice that's what I predict you'll
think you know if if history is any
indicator but anyway t-shirts on there
we got some lightweight hoodies on there
which joke are you even down for the
lightweight hood because so far people
everyone know every single person who
was like siding with jockle in real life
I'm not talking about Internet siding
with charcoal saying yeah hoodies are
for like when you're cold you need a
heavy hoodie otherwise why are you even
wearing a hoodie just wear a shirt right
everybody you know everybody okay let's
talk about something is just ridiculous
the likelihood II have changed their
mind everything is fine Dave Bergman be
all good deal
yeah oh yeah you say I was wrong
yeah this hoodie is outstanding oh yeah
I've actually already knew that that's
why we did it but lightweight hoodies
but rash guards for jiu-jitsu and other
items in life man no you know some
women's stuff hats all the some cool
stuff I think it's cool people seem to
think it's cool go in there you like
something get something choco store.com
Ron how do you like that how do you like
the tea it's really good
definitely well yes the best tea you've
ever tried it's better than strawberry
Quik it's way better it's very quick I
definitely would drink this strawberry
Quik I mean if it has extra but benefits
of the probiotics and the protein maybe
I'll drink a little okay but cool if
it's just strawberry Quik Ron has been
drinking
jakka white tea with pomegranate
anyway certified organic but the good
thing about it is it it after you finish
the skin you can deadlift eight thousand
pounds and that's that's proof that's
pretty fact 100% proven as a as a for
many former 18 Delta medic I can help
you run through the test and you'll see
it's a hundred percent make sure you
subscribe to the podcast if you don't
subscribe to it already which is kind of
ridiculous you know yeah oh yeah oh and
I just read a review yeah a guy said um
he was going through like his top 5
podcasts and then our podcast came in to
his world as this is the podcast that I
most subscribe and unsubscribe to okay
yeah and he says I subscribe to it
because it's got great information on
leadership and human nature and history
and war he was but I unsubscribe to it
because they spend a lot of times on
some episodes talking about jiu-jitsu
which I don't do and this wasn't a
review on iTunes this was a review that
he wrote in a blog Oh
and tagged me in it on Twitter his own
blog his own blog because people tagged
you in their blog so you'll win it and
reposted yeah this is great so I read it
and I just commented back to him I said
it sounds like you need to start doing
jujitsu hmmm that was the problem later
yeah so there you go whoever that guy
was seemed like a nice enough guy but
didn't want to do the jujitsu that's
that so yeah subscribe and don't forget
about the warrior kid podcast yes sir oh
my daughter has a question for the
warrior could borrow yeah we'll go over
it later
I don't care pass it on to uncle Jake if
you would oh yeah so yeah that's a good
one or your kid podcast is have you ever
listened to worry kid podcast with your
kids I have not no no it's what it is
the basic principles of life I try and
convey it in a way for kids that they
can understand it that they can
appreciate it and that they listen to it
as you know I'm always quoting you with
my with my kids like discipline equals
freedom right right do the right thing
and then they'll let you do more and you
know what it doesn't matter who you are
as a dad your kids are not gonna listen
to you as much as you want them to so
it's good if you come at them from
another angle the other angle is uncle
Jake who can tell him about discipline
equals freedom
so anyways warrior kid podcast check
that out and don't forget about that
warrior kids soap from Irish Oaks ranch
calm Aidan's making soap as a kid but
he's got his own business and he's
making soap on a rope right in yeah he's
a 550 little piece of paracord yeah it's
good so you got that going on mm-hmm and
then you got YouTube subscribe to
YouTube so you can see echoes legit
videos and if you want to know what Ron
sure looks like very handsome then you
can watch this complete episode on
YouTube you can also see ecla spit
against videos
you know it's a lot of time and effort
into him yes which means that he puts a
lot of time and effort into them there
you go yeah and it some of them are good
some of them he puts a little too much
time and effort into you know okay cool
the same yeah yeah it what else
psychological warfare if you having if
you're having issues a lot of issues or
just a few issues on the path you know
moments a weakness where you don't want
to get up as early as maybe you think
you should and you don't feel like it
that's what it is when you don't feel
like it this is a little bit of help to
push you through any moment diet stuff
wake up stuff workout skipping workout
stuff that was a big one for me back in
that day by the way oh just by this loss
album leg workouts not anymore anyway
you get this album's called
psychological warfare little tracks on
there Jocko telling us helping us
through our moments of weakness really
easy a hundred percent effectiveness my
experience cool check out flipside
canvas it's my brother Dakota Meyers
Dakota Meyer he is taking cool hidden
images you know and putting him on
canvas vinyl in America here and sending
them to you if you want them you you
know he has a straight up Jaco series
now good yeah it's so epic anyways check
that out support Dakota into what the
code is doing you know it's like if you
want cut if you want costume stuff just
hit Dakota up on on Twitter as Dakota's
like the nicest person
you seem pretty nice to Ron but the code
is really nice yeah and he's always want
to help out so yeah there you go flip
side cameras comm also on it on it calm
slash Jocko by the way go that this is
where you can get your fitness gear
whether it be for home
you got a commercial gym whatever you
like also some good what would you call
the elk bars snack food yeah like you
nuts now yeah it's like which hell you
ain't even
the word healthy yes cuz the stigma like
the cliche like Buzzard yeah I'm shocked
yeah yeah anyway there's a lot of good
stuff on there ah Netcom get something
from there too
yes keep you on the path and in the game
as it were a bunch of books I written a
bunch of books Mikey the Dragons that's
for younger kids way the warrior kid
that's for medium age kids marks mission
is the follow-on to that the new book
three of where the warrior kid is coming
out it's called where there's a will it
will be available should be available
right now how you like that for
pre-order on Amazon this mu equals
freedom Field Manual extreme ownership
first book I wrote with my brother lave
babban about combat leadership and how
you can apply it to your business into
your life and then the dichotomy of
leadership which is the follow-up to
that book which is also about leadership
but it gets granular on those principles
and on being a balanced leader which is
the best kind of leader to be national
in front that's my leadership
consultancy and what we do is solve
problems through leadership it's me Lafe
babban JP Danelle Dave Burke good yeah
good deal Dave Burke Flynn Cochran
Mike's really Mike bimah and Jason
Gardner mr. Ely's Jason Garner doesn't
really have a nickname yeah just a
matter of clan on that one go to a salon
front comm if you want us to come and
help you work through whatever issues
you have in your organization that will
do with leadership the muster coming up
May 23rd and 24th in Chicago September
19th and 20th in Denver December 4th and
5th and Sydney Australia
these are leadership conferences events
gathering this is musters yeah so it's a
muster that's what we call it we call
the muster and if you want to come to it
you've got a register pretty quick they
all the ones that we've done these are
seven eight and nine this year that all
of them have sold out so these are gonna
sell out as well if you want to come get
there early I won't be
to help you if you contact me a week
prior to the event and say hey I really
wanted to go can you you know can throw
me a couple tickets and I know you for I
went to high school you with you or
whatever I can't help you
you can't come don't be mad at me then
EF online that is our online training
for leadership for people that can't
come to the muster or you got a big
company with 28,000 employees and you
want them all to get trained in the
leadership principles that we teach at
Ashkelon front go to EF online comm and
you can get your whole organization
aligned and running in the right
direction and we've got EF overwatch as
well and what we're doing with EF
overwatch is taking proven leaders from
spec ops and from combat aviation and
putting them into civilian jobs civilian
sector leadership and don't always think
you've got a hire somebody that knows
everything
technical about the situation hire
someone for their leadership capability
it's easier to teach them the industry
than it is to teach someone leadership
so EF overwatch comm that's what you
need it's you need leadership and if you
want to connect with Ron he's on the
interwebs he's kind of young on the
interwebs you're not super advanced I'm
trying to learn especially with
Instagram and so I'm trying to just
slowly dip my toes into that and the
toes are being a get get that connection
with the people who who feel connected
to this story and yeah it's awesome if
you do go on Twitter it's Ron underscore
396 for Instagram which apparently is
Ron's Ron's gonna be the gram is in the
gram that's your main one that's me
that's that's my focus
that's your photos okay it's got the
mission focus and that is Ron underscore
sure SH you are er
and then we also echo Charles and I are
on those as well and we're also on the
bulk and we are echo is that echo
Charles and I am at Jocko Willick echo
you got anything else no thank you Ron
young man Ron congratulations
no any closing thoughts are on so again
thank you guys so much for having me
today um whenever I come to talk about
myself I could I love talking about
myself like getting most SF guys - I'd
rather you know my wife says that you
know I came a green beret and it's the
quite professional they you know you you
know you just got you do the mission you
talk about it and then I'm moved over to
the Secret Service which is you know as
they kind of tagline like standing on
the sidelines of history like I want to
do cool things I want to be there but I
never want anybody to talk about me or
look at me or do any of that but I
appreciate the chance to come here today
because you know when I got the metal
you know as part of processing it and
trying to figure out what did I want to
do with it
you know like writing right now from the
global war on terrorism we've been
fighting for 17 straight years like
Green Berets you know that's that's
where my heart is like they've been just
out there get it on the entire time I
it's mind-boggling to me that I am the
only living recipient right now
representing that group
Robbie Miller who was in alpha 3 3 he
was on the same deployment as me he here
in the Medal of Honor in January of 2008
barely taking the fight to the enemy but
unfortunately he was killed he was the
first green Bray in this war and now I'm
a second but I'm the first who can
actually get out there and
share I share my story not so you can be
like Iran's awesomely bronzed just
another dude on a team who had a an okay
day and a bat in a horrible day
but story so I can tell people that
stories like that are going on
constantly and you know I'm just I'm
here to represent those guys who don't
care if you you know you could give them
give them an award not give them an
award give them a pat on the back they
don't care they just they believe in the
mission they're out there doing the
mission they're missing birthdays and
anniversaries and all those things for
this country and you know that's why I'm
here is just to remind people about
those guys not so much myself and you
know to be able to you know just share a
little bit that story and then you know
also to you know say thanks to my family
for being so supportive it's you know I
mean I'm you know I got a medal because
I was you know taking care of other
people but I have a huge support
structure behind me my wife Miranda like
I said was sitting quizzing me through
the queue course those were our maybe
not our first date but by like week two
or three like okay you're in the circle
now you know you got to help me cuz I
can't give up a hole I want to see you
for a weekend but I can't give up a
whole weekend and that's that he so just
the support that she's given from then
to now to you know having a baby or
being pregnant with with some group
Green Beret he was overseas he comes
back sees a baby born like alright good
luck with that kid I got to go back and
take care of people so the amount of
support that I've had there and then my
kids just putting up with all this stuff
too and just be able to say thanks to
them on a on a bigger front I appreciate
that
and
you know I touched on it a little bit
with with my cancer story I definitely
don't want to be I don't want to be some
like sad story like oh this guy sucks to
be him like or anything I just share it
just because I know there were other
people out there who are getting
diagnosed with cancer and they're
getting those phone calls and I remember
that I remember that first call I got
where it was like you know there's
nothing you can do today and and he
meant like it was like a Friday
afternoon I just found out the day
before and it's going to the weekend but
that that that crush of that was nothing
you can do like what do you mean and so
you know that if I can just put out that
story that there's always hope there's
always more you can do and you know the
cancer fight is not like combat where
you had to go punch somebody in the face
or shoot somebody in the face and have
that like the the cancer fight is you
know getting up and eating when you
don't want to eat it's the last thing in
the world you want to do or you got to
work out well let's just go for a walk
you know like just just those things I
just want to you know have a moment to
be able to anybody who's being affected
by that just say you know you're you're
not alone and it's tough it sucks
however you got there doesn't matter
don't worry about I don't to worry for
myself why I got it
but it's just it's it's just the next
challenge keep putting your one foot in
front of the other and yeah that's life
awesome and well um once again thanks
thanks for coming on man it's been
awesome meet you and thanks to Zack your
buddy Zack who kind of linked us up and
it was cool that you reached out to me
and it took us a long time to make this
happen with everything that's going on
in your world and I'm glad we're able to
do it so thanks for coming on and
absolutely my pleasure
obviously thanks for your service and
your sacrifice for what you did for this
country and you know not just for what
you did for the country while you're in
the military while you and the Secret
Service but also look right now setting
an example for everyone for everyone
that's out there for me for everyone to
follow and know that we can step up our
game that we can go on we can do better
and we can fight harder and that's what
I see when I see you and thanks for
doing that for me and for everyone else
and obviously thanks to everyone else
out there in uniform that is defending
our flag and our country to those that
are serving to those that have served
thanks to all of you out there thanks to
the police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers Border Patrol
Secret Service first time mentioned for
the Secret Service and all the other
first responders thanks for keeping us
safe here at home and for everyone else
out there remember that you might have
to fight uphill you might have to fight
against a hardened enemy that has more
guns and more people than you and even
in those situations remember the path of
Ron sure and the rests of Special Forces
OD a three three three six remember to
stand by your brothers
remember to pick up that weapon remember
to put one foot in front of the other
and remember to keep getting after it
and until next time this is Ron Shaw and
echo and Jocko out